bienvenue chers collègues il nous
appartient d'effectuer plusieurs
nominations de rapporteur et donc je
vous propose d'effectuer ces nominations
avant de débuter notre audition tout
d'abord le bureau de la commission du 31
janvier dernier contenu du contexte de
crise qui prévaut dans le secteur
agricole a décidé d'avancer la création
de la mission d'évaluation à 3 ans de la
loi égalim 2 cette mission d'évaluation
était initialement prévue à l'automne
prochain et nous avons fait le choix en
bureau de l'avancée dès à présent je
vous propose donc la nomination de
Monsieur Frédéric descray pour
Renaissance madame anneelore babo pour
le modem ça c'est pour la majorité et
puis pour l'opposition madame Aurélie
Trouvé du groupe LFI et il nous reste un
nom à pourvoir et je vous propose
d'attendre la fin de la réunion pour le
nommer puisque nous sommes en attente du
dernier nom personne n'y voit
d'inconvénient bien par ailleurs le
Sénat a adopté le 13 décembre dernier un
projet de loi portant diverses
dispositions d'adaptation du droit de
l'Union européenne un projet de loi
d'adu qui est un instrument législatif
qui est utilisé assez régulièrement pour
adapter le droit national au mesures qui
figurent dans les règlements européens
et transposer donc des directives
européennes ce projet de loi il a été
renvoyé à la commission des lois et
cette dernière a sollicité l'avis de la
commission des affaires économiques sur
se articles de ce texte les articles
1emers 2 3 18 19 33 et 34 et donc nous
avons une délégation sur le fond sur ces
articles c'est un projet de loi qui sera
examiné par notre commission le 6 mars
prochain et je vous propose de nommer
monsieur Stéphane vogetta comme
rapporteur de ce texte personne n'y voit
d'inconvénient je vous remercie de plus
notre commission devrait examiner la
proposition de loi visant à instaurer la
transparence sur la fabrication des
plats servis en restauration lors de la
seconde semaine de l'assemblée du mois
de mars je vous propose de désigner
monsieur Christopher weisberg comme
rapporteur de ce texte personne n'y voit
d'inconvénient je vous remercie enfin je
vous rappelle c'est encore dans les
nominations j'en ai deux à vous faire
faire le je vous rappelle que le bureau
de la commission a décidé récemment de
la création de 8 missions d'application
de loi à 6 mois il nous reste à désigner
les rapporteurs de deux d'entre elles il
est proposé pour la mission
d'application de la loi du 10 juillet
2023 pour renforcer la prévention de la
lutte contre l'intensification et
l'extension du risque incendie de nommer
comme rapporteur monsieur Luc lamirot et
Madame Sophie panonacle ici présente ici
présent membre de droit en tant que
rapporteur du texte et Monsieur Stéphane
de l'otrait groupe socialiste et Hervé
de l'épinot groupe RN rapporteur de
l'opposition personne n'y voit
d'inconvénient je vous remercie dernière
nomination on vous propose la mission
d'application de la loi du 20 juillet
2023 pour faciliter la mise en œuvre des
objectifs de lutte contre l'arti
officialisation des sols et renforcer
l'accompagnement des élus locaux et on
vous propose de nommer comme rapporteur
monsieur Bastien Marchive membre de
droit pour la majorité et Madame
Mathilde ignet du groupe LFI
corapporteur de l'opposition personne
n'y voit
d'inconvénient je vous remercie j'en ai
terminé pour ces annonces et nous allons
rentrer dans le vif du sujet monsieur le
ministre chers collègues la commission
des affaires économiques auditionne cet
après-midi monsieur Marc fenau ministre
de l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire monsieur le ministre nous
vous avions déjà entendu dans cette même
salle il y a tout juste 2 mois le 6
décembre 2023 peu de semaines se sont
donc écoulées et pourtant les
circonstances sont profondément
différentes il y a de mois vous étiez
ministre du gouvernement d'Élisabeth
borne vous occupez aujourd'hui les mêmes
fonctions au sein du gouvernement de
Gabriel Atal il y a 2 mois vous veniez
nous présenter un projet de loi
d'orientation agricole que vous
souhaitiez concis considérant que ce qui
relève du domaine réglementaire devrait
être renvoyé au règlement ce qui relève
du budget devrait être renvoyé au budget
ce projet loi se limitant à une dizaine
d'articles était donc plutôt orienté sur
la formation et l'attractivité depuis le
6 décembre les agriculteurs français et
plus globalement les agriculteurs
européens ont exprimé leur malaise dans
des manifestations de grande ampleur
nombre de députés et notamment de
députés de la commission des affaires
économiques de la majorité de
l'opposition de tous les groupes sont
allés à la rencontre de ces manifestants
sur les barrages ou dans leurs
exploitations agricole démontrant en
cela encore une fois leur proximité avec
cette profession leur sensibilité aux
difficultés à l'origine de ce mouvement
et leur écoute attentive du monde
agricole qui illustre les nombreux
travaux menés ces derniers mois par nos
commissaires cette colère exprimé des
revendications multiples sur la
fiscalité du gazoel Non Routier sur
l'achat de leur production au juste prix
sur la multiplication des normes et leur
enchevêtrement sur la bureaucratisation
de leur activité sur les délais de
versement des aides diverses sur la
concurrence de produits importés soumis
à des normes plus souples et cetera et
cetera le Premier ministre et vous-même
avez entendu ses revendications et
formulé de multiples propositions le 6
janvier et le 1er février que vous allez
probablement rappeler dans votre
intervention ces annonces ont conduit
les principales organisations syndicales
à lever les barrages mais vous le savez
la traduction de ces annonces en acte
est attendue au plus vite une échéance
est déjà fixée le salon de l'agriculture
à la fin de ce mois une délégation de
notre commission s'y rendra d'ailleurs
le 28 février dès lors quelles sont les
mesures réglementaires que vous comptez
mettre en œuvre d'ici quelques semaines
en quoi le projet de loi d'orientation
agricole sera-t-il enrichi pour ce qui
relève du domaine législatif et quel est
le calendrier envisagé pour l'exam de ce
texte certaines dispositions ne pourront
pas être prises à court terme sur le
point essentiel de la rémunération le
ministre Bruno Lemer a ainsi annoncé une
mission sur l'évaluation des lois égalim
de son côté le bureau de la commission
des affaires économiques et vous l'avez
entendu en tout début de cette réunion a
décidé d'avancer l'évaluation à 3 ans de
la loi égalim 2 parallèlement nous avons
déjà créé une mission d'application de
la loi descrousaill renforçant
l'équilibre dans les relations
commerciales entre fournisseurs et
distributeurs qui s'intéresse également
à la mise en œuvre de la récente loi sur
l'avancement des négociations
commerciales quels sont les principale
piste d'évolution qui vous semble devoir
être privilégié sans plus attendre
monsieur le ministre vous avez la
parole merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés merci de m'accueillir et merci
de votre invitation à un moment
effectivement
particulier après une une audition
effectivement il y a 2 mois on nous
avion dilleurs évoqué un certain nombre
des sujets qui sont sur la table sur
lesquels il nous faut désormais avancer
nous avions avant ce moment de
mobilisation des agriculteurs qui est un
moment d'ailleurs français européen ce
qui pose la question on y reviendra
peut-être de la question européenne et
du rapport aux politiques européennes et
donc je voulais juste devant vous avant
de me soumettre à la loi des des
questions ou des interventions vous dire
ce que nous avons fait ce que nous
posons sur la table d'abord il y a des
mesures qui seront de domaine législatif
on y reviendra puis il y a des mesures
de relève qui relèvent plutôt de
l'exécutif qui relèvent du réglementaire
et sur lequel de toute façon l'assemblée
est appelée à effectuer ses missions de
contrôle et d'évaluation alors je vais
pas ber est l'enciè des sujets mais dire
que d'abord on a beaucoup travaillé avec
sous l'égit du Premier ministre avec
Christophe Béchu et Bruno Lemer on voit
bien vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs dans
votre propos à quel point ces sujets
sont enchevêtrés sur le C thème d'abord
les premières avancées concrètes sur
cinq points particuliers le premier sur
les questions de trésorerie le décret un
décret qui va permettre aux agriculteurs
dès ce mois de février une avance de 50
% sur le remboursement pour seul partiel
de l'assis sur les produits énergétiques
concernant le GNR
et sur lequel nous avons aussi annulé la
hausse de ou la baisse de
défiscalisation pour être plus
précis ça a été annoncé par le Premier
ministre lors d'un déplacement en Haute
Garonne c'est à peu près 230 millions
d'euros qui seront ainsi déployés en
terme de trésorerie par les exploitation
agricole je rappelle en outre qu'en lien
avec le ministère de l'économie et des
finances et le budget nous allons faire
en sorte que désormais le la déduction
se fasse en pied de facture mais ça ça
sera à partir du 1er juillet ce qui
permettra c'est à la fois une
simplification et une trésorerie
continue une paire de trésorerie qui ne
qui ne sera plus le cas on voit bien
qu'il y a un certain nombre
d'agriculteurs qui contenu de la
trésorerie est obligé de faire des prè
court terme simplement dans l'attente du
remboursement de la défiscalisation
deuxième sujet le sujet des éleveurs
beauvin
euh notamment la maladie hémorragique
épisotique dans sa première phase je dis
devant vous très simplement nous ne
sommes qu'à la première phase il n'est
pas impossible que nous ayons une
résurgence il est même fort probable que
nous ayons une résurgence au printemps
prochain mais le l'objectif c'était de
prendre en charge à la fois les frais
vétérinaires et la mortalité des animaux
à hauteur de 90 % j'ajoute que nous
continuons à ACC donc le dispositif est
en place depuis le début de la semaine
on a présenté ça aux professionnels ça a
été fait très en lien avec eux pour
faire en sorte que ça puisse se déployer
dès le mois de février queil a les
premiers dossiers puissent être examinés
et pris en charge financièrement dès le
mois de février je vous donne quand même
un ordre de grandeur la gripe avière
c'était 1400 ou 1500 Doss la maladie
hémorragique épisotique c'est 4000 plus
de 4000 dossiers près de 4000 dossiers
donc c'est une charge administrative qui
va être évidemment très lourde
l'occasion de rendre d'ailleurs hommage
au passage au aux agents du ministère et
aux agents des autres ministères qui
traitent avec le monde agricole on a
entendu parfois des
expressions que je regrette profondément
moi je suis absolument en soutien des
agents du ministère s'il y a des
règlements ou des lois qui ne
conviennent pas c'est plutôt ça relève
plutôt du législatif ou de l'exécutif et
je trouve que parfois les expressions
qui ont eu lieu sur les agents sont fort
regrettables 3è point sur les
indemnisations des sujets climatiques à
la fois le process qui se déroule comme
prévu sur les montants qu'on avait prévu
mais avec un fond d'urgence
complémentaire pour la tempête tiarant
je rappelle qu'il y a dispositif
assuranciel qui a le dispositif
catastrophe naturel là c'est plutôt pour
le pas de calis il a le fond d'urgence
tel qu'il avait été déployé et par
ailleurs un fond qui permettra de
recouvrer des moyens de production au
travers de d'un soutien à
l'investissement c'est ça qu'on va
déployer dans les semaines qui viennent
mais on a abondé le fond sur ce est là
je rajoute euh non je continue sur le
sujet de la la simplification euh sur
lequel vous m'interrogerez certainement
d'abord le décret sur le curage des
cours d'eau est paru alors le problème
est né et est apparu dans le Pas de
Calais mais évidemment c'est un décret
qui couvre l'ensemble du territoire
national c'était très attendu pas
seulement d'ailleurs par les
agriculteurs c'est un décret de bon sens
par ailleurs on a mené un certain nombre
de travaux réglementaire d'abord la
mettre la mise à terme d'un régime
d'ction sur les délais de recours contre
les projets agricoles
pour le ramener à ce qui est le droit
commun c'est-à-dire 2 mois deuxièmement
général de manière générale accélérer le
traitement des contentieux contre les
qui peuvent avoir lieu sur les projets
de stockage de l'eau ou sur les
bâtiments agricoles élevages ou autres
et puis il y avait une obligation qui
était prévue de mise en norme
d'accessibilité pour tous les bâtiments
agricoles il y avait quelque chose dans
l'ordre du bon sens pour faire en sorte
qu'il puissent s déroger pour des
raisons qui paraissent évidentes sur le
court terme également j'ai annoncé
vendredi dernier dans l'éos et dans le
gare un plan de soutien assez massif à
la viticulture qui comprend à la fois
des mesures d'urgence pour 80 millions
d'euros qui viennent aider la trésorerie
de cy qui sont implactés soit par une
baisse des prix soit par des sujets des
aléas de nature diverses climatiqu ou
conséquences des aléas climatiques et
puis de des mesures plus structurelles
150 millions d'euros pour faire en sorte
que nous pensions maintenant une
restructuration du vinoble on a un
sujet de structurel de surproduction ça
n'est pas valable d'ailleurs qu'en
France qui nécessite qu'on puisse
restructurer le vigob
développer des spages qui sont plus ceux
qui sont consommés aujourd'hui et
restructurer globalement le vigob ça
viendra s'adosser ces 150 millions à 250
millions qui seront qui seront pris sur
l'OCM vit vinicol et donc c'est 400
millions qui seront consacrés à cette
restructuration du VINov c'est un
important un point important de de vous
le dire un soutien à la filière bio même
si je sais que ça fait objet de débat
qui est prévu avec 50 millions d'euros
supplémentaires qui viennent s'ajouter
aux 100 millions d'euros environ qui ont
été déployés sur l'année 2023 et la
filière sera réunie dès cette semaine
pour regarder à la fois les filières qui
doivent être priorisées et regarder les
besoins qui peuvent s'exprimer sur cette
filière on sait évidemment 4è point vous
l'avez dit monsieur le Président les
lois et Galim avec un comité de
négociation que j'ai tenu en présence de
Bruno Le
Maire pour notamment faire en sorte que
nous puissions renforcer les contrôles
lors de ce comité des négociations
commerciales on a vit un certain nombre
d'acteurs expliquer que 2022 2023 la loi
avait été plutôt respectée dans son it
dans sa lettre même s'il y a toujours
des gens qui essaient d'échapper à la
loi mais que depuis que les négociations
étaient ouvertes depuis le mois de
novembre décembre il y avait un certain
nombre de gens par des pratiques de
nature diverse qui essay de contourner
la loi on voit bien les sujets il y a en
particulier le contournement avec les
centrales d'achat européennes il y a le
sujet de bien vérifier que les marques
de distributeur puisque c'est le projet
qui avait été rajouté dans la loi
décroosailles et MDD puisse bien
respecter la question de la marche avant
du prix comme c'est prévu dans la loi de
base et la loi des crousailles et donc
on continue ses travaux à la fois sur
les contrôles avec l'expression qu'a eu
le ministre d'économie et des Finances
très clair sur le fait que les sanctions
tomberont là où elles doivent tomber
pour après aller plus loin on regardera
éventuellement les ajustements qu'il
faut faire faut attendre aussi peut-être
que les rapports puissent être produits
et qu'on puisse tirer enseignement du
cycle de négociation je rappelle que sur
1000 contrats il y a 120 contrôles qui
se sont
révélés incorrect et qui donc vont
donner lieu à des procédures sur le
sujet européen 1 enfin nous avons obtenu
une la dérogation qui avait été portée
par la France je le rappelle je l'avais
dit d'ailleurs ici cette commission sur
les 4% de jcher c'est un élément forme
me semble-t-il et un premier élément il
y en aura d'autres sur lequel nous
devons travailler avec la commission de
prise en compte des impératif de
souveraineté alimentaire dans un moment
où je le rappelle l'Union européenne
importe en 2023 40 millions de tonnes de
céréales la France est exportatrice mais
l'Union européenne est très puissamment
importatrice du fait de la structure du
marché et parfois du fait aussi des
dérèglements climatiques de la même
manière la France a obtenu la mise en
place d'une clause de sauvegarde dans le
cadre commercial adopté en soutien à
l'Ukraine ça va concerner la volaille
les œufs le sucre et nous travaillons à
leur extension sur les céréales parce
que c'est un sujet important et le
travail se poursuit avec la commission
pour regarder le détails fin notamment
les années de référence qui est un sujet
évidemment très important j'en viens
aussi au chantier de moyen terme en
évoquant ce qui vous concerne en premier
plan le projet de loi du que le
Parlement examinera au premier semestre
2024 l'objectif est que les deux
lectures assemblées Sénat se fasse d'ici
le mois de juin pouron puisse tenir une
commission mixte paritaire dans cet
horizon-là donc voilà pour les les
aspects calendaire euh ce texte est en
train d'être enrichi notamment autour
des propositions sur lesquelles avait
qui avaient déjà été avancé dans le PACT
euh je pense en particulier la question
de la souveraineté alimentaire je pense
à la question d'accélération
d'accélération en lien avec la
simplification des traitements des
projets de stockage de l'eau ou des
bâtiments d'élevage euh à travers la
présomption d'urgence un certain nombre
de sujets sont sur la table l'objectif
c'est que nous puissions envoyer au
Conseil d'État d'ici la fin du mois de
février le texte puis qu'il doit
repasser au Conseil d'État pour une
délibération ensuite au Conseil des
ministres bien sûr il y avait un certain
nombre d'entre vous a exprimé le fait
que la loi n'était pas ambitieuse dans
ses débuts saisissons le moment je
prends acte du fait que il y avait une
nécessité d'ailleurs ça faisait l'objet
de débat il compris en interne
ministériel de rajouter des choses mais
euh il me semble que c'est ce qu'on va
essayer de faire c'est de travailler sur
des objets qui permettent de forter les
aspects de souveraineté et de le
traduire aussi là où il y a besoin de
traduction législative sur les questions
d'accélération et de clarification on
aura aussi des éléments je le dis tout à
l'heure je le dirai redirai peut-être
tout à l'heure sur la question de la et
donc c'est important qu'on fasse ce
travail et je je sais qu'il y a des
travaux d'abord il y a eu des échange
avec un certain nombre d'entre vous dans
le cadre de la préparation de la loi et
du pacte et les travaux vont reprendre
ou se poursuivre pour faire en sorte que
nous puissions avancer sur le sujet j'en
viens aussi au sujet qui fait beaucoup
débat c'est le sujet de la mise en pause
du plan écofito 2030 une pause ça veut
dire ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
qu'on a besoin de prendre le temps
reconnaissons que les plans écofitau il
datent de 2009 et que globalement il a
pas tenu les objectifs qui étaient ceux
qui lui éta assigné donc on prenne
quelques semaines pour regarder un
certain nombre d'éléments sur lequel
nous devons travailler il me semble que
c'est important sur quoi nous allons
travailler concrètement d'abord sur les
indicateurs et dans une logique de non
surtransposition que nous puissions
disoser d'indicateurs qui soi de
d'échelle européenne sinon on va
mélanger on va on va combiner des des
des indicateurs qui serai pas de même
nature ce qui est un peu regrettable
quand on est dans l'espace européen il y
a quelque chose qui qui est un peu
incohérent et puis deux tout le monde
l'a dit en tout cas beaucoup de gens
l'ont dit l'indicateur dit NODU tel
qu'il était formulé il ne pondérait pas
son son poids de la toxicité des
produits qui étaient les leurs ce qui
fait que vous passiez un produit très
toxique avec un passage avec un produit
moins toxique avec trois passages vous
avez un indicateur qui pouvait se
dégrader c'est un biais qui existait
depuis le début qui a souvent été
souligné sur lequel nous devons
travailler puis nous devons travailler
aussi sur les mesures de simplification
mais l'objectif c'est que d'ici la le
mois de février les choses soient
remises en route je tiendrai un COS
cofito la semaine prochaine avec mes
collègues Béchu et retaillo mais sur les
simplifications je pense
au je pense au registre
numérique je pense au registre numérique
euh dans dans un objectif de non
surtransposition dernier chantier de
moyen terme que je voudrais évoquer
celui de relations avec l'administration
de l'État avec l'ofb enfin sujets qui
ont déjà été évoqués y compris ici nous
lançons un chantier pour améliorer la
manière dont se déroulent les les
contrôles et leurs perceptions en éco
notamment au rapport qui avait été
présenté par vos collègues Blin et
martinau sur le sujet l'objectif en
terme de calendrier de présenter de
premières avancées là aussi au salut au
salon de l'agriculture et puis je
vraister juste évoquer juste pardon je
suis un peu long mais le temps un peu
plus long d'abord on a un chantier
européen qui est désormais
ouvert le sujet jacher a permis d'ouvrir
un une brèche si je peux dire dans le
dialogue européen je note avec intérêt
et satisfaction les déclarations qui ont
été faites par la présidente de la
Commission européenne euh se déclarant
se déclarant ouverte enfin à des
simplifications immédiates et une
réflexion générale sur ce que doit être
la PAC nous avons d'ailleurs été
sollicités directement pour faire des
propositions au niveau français et j'ai
dans le dialog que j'ai eu avec mes
collègues avec un certain nombre de
collègues mercredi dernier quand j'étais
à Bruxelles on est convenu que nous
porterions collectivement un certain
nombre de de de de simplification dans
la PAC alors parfois ça se fait dans à
cadre à ISO cadre pardon réglementaire
ou plutôt législatif parfois ça
nécessitera de faire évoluer l'acte de
base mais ça c'est le travail que nous
allons faire avec nos collègues
européens comme sur la BCAE 8 sur les
jachers il y a besoin de trouver des
coalitions ce qui a pesé aussi dans la
décision c'est que nous étions plus
d'une vingtaine de pays qui euh avait
suivi la France dans le registre qui
était le sien donc c'est le sujet de la
PAC de et de sa simplification c'est le
sujet du travail sur l'Ukraine je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure et c'est le sujet
aussi euh de mieux quand même conjuguer
euh Green Deal et souveraineté on voit
bien que le sujet qui est interrogé par
le monde agricole il est il est là
principalement et il n'est pas interrogé
que par le monde agricole français il
est interrogé par le monde agricole
européen enfin nous avons besoin de
travailler sur la question du revenu euh
je pense à la question des retraites le
rapport qui a été formulé conformément à
la loi la PPL de Monsieur div a été
produit il y a des effets de bord et des
effits de biaet l'objectif c'est de
faire en sorte que nous à partir de ce
rapport nous regardions nous n'arrêtions
pas le travail et que nous regardions
comment on fait en sorte que par rapport
à ces effets de bord et des effets de
billet nous y répondions là c'est quand
même le travail de quelques semaines
voir un tout petit peu plus pour essayer
d'avancer sur ce sujet-là mais
l'objectif c'est bien d'être au
rendez-vous des attentes d'abord de ce
que nous avions fait dans les lois
chassigne 1 et chassigne 2 et
deuxièmement de prolonger par rapport à
l'esprit de la loi tel qu'il avait été
voté deuxième sujet européen pour le
coup c'est égalim européen
euh j'ai rencontré le commissaire
Thierry Breton sur lequel je m'appuie
beaucoup pour faire en sorte que nous
puissions mettre au débat cette question
d'un égalimme Européen parce que ça
viendrait aussi mettre à mal un certain
nombre de biais dans une
réglementation strictement française je
rappelle toujours qu'égalim c'est une
surtransposition française au bon sens
du
terme mais on a besoin de le faire à
l'échelle européenne cont de ce que sont
les pratiques de la grande distribution
il me semble que c'est un un élément
très important trème élément au niveau
européen c'est les
clauses de réciprocité des clauses
miroir au travers des accords la France
par la voie du président de la
République s'est opposé au Mercosur je
n'y reviens pas il ne peut y avoir
d'accord en l'état tel qu'il est proposé
je le répète je le président de la
République l'a dit et d'ailleurs les
faits viennent de parler pour ça on a
besoin d'avoir des accords commerciaux
mais on a besoin aussi d'avoir des
accords commerciaux qui prennent réell
en compte la question la question des
clauses miroir et des questions des
réciprocités sinon c'est
incompréhensible dans l'espace européen
de trouver une trajectoire qui combine
souveraineté et transition parce que
nous avons besoin de transition et dans
l'espace extraeuropéen d'avoir dans les
accords commerciaux des clauses qui sur
un certain nombre de sujets permettent
de
garantir une concurrence qui soit moins
déloyale et puis évidemment une force de
contrôle on voit bien que dans un
certain nombre de cas et j'en termine
monsieur le Président on a besoin
d'avoir une force de contrôle qui
permette aux opérateurs européens de se
garantir de que les normes que nous nous
fixons elles sont bien respectées par
les produits qui viennent à l'extérieur
de l'extérieur de nos frères dès lors
que nous avons posé le principe qu'elle
ne pouvait pas rentrer il faut que ça
puisse s'appliquer et là on a besoin
d'un sujet de force de contrôle qui soit
nationale mais aussi européenne pour que
les les petits malins ne viennent pas se
glisser dans les interstices de nos
absences de contrôle voilà monsieur le
Président ce que je voulais vous dire
j'ai déjà été trop long mais ça
permettra aussi peut-être de d'avoir
répondu à certaines premières questions
avant de vous écouter merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre je vous propose de
passer aux orateurs de groupe vous
connaissez le principe 4 minutes par
orateur de groupe inclus votre réponse
monsieur le ministre et je demande à
chaque orateur de laisser au minimum une
minute de réponse donc à 3 minutes si
vous allez jusqu'à 3 minutes je coupe on
commence tout de suite avec le groupe
Renaissance et c'est le Ministre
Stéphane traver qui porte la parole du
groupe c'est à vous merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre bienvenue
ces dernières semaines ont été marquées
par une mobilisation agricole qui a
rassemblé l'ensemble des secteurs de
production et des territoires et cette
mobilisation elle s'est aussi répandue
dans dans de nombreux pays de l'Union
les agriculteurs ont souhaité ici
réaffirmer une ambition agricole
nationale et européenne pour garantir la
souveraineté alimentaire en France et en
Europe et puis la question de lever les
freins qui les entravent dans leur
quotidien comment continuer à produire
plus et mieux comment lutter
efficacement contre le changement
climatique dont les agriculteurs sont
les premières victimes aujourd'hui
sachant également qu'ils ont entre les
mains les solutions ou une partie des
des solutions comment leur éviter de
subir les affres de la concurrence
déloyales à laquelle ils sont soumis euh
par un certain nombre de pays étrangers
quel avenir français et européen
voulons-nous pour garantir un revenu et
répondre aux attentes sociétales vous
avez été monsieur le ministre et nous
voulons vous en féliciter en première
ligne euh pendant cette crise avec le
Premier ministre et nous voulons saluer
la réactivité et la force des
propositions du gouvernement votre
réponse est celle du Premier ministre à
reposer sur des principes clairs et
ambitieux des mesures d'urgence posé
rapidement sur la table un calendrier
pour qu'avant le prochain Salon de
l'Agriculture une base d'accord puisse
être formulé sur différents sujets et
une méthode européenne pour engager tous
nos partenaires dans une politique
cohérente au service d'une agriculture
européenne sur Scine et durable qui
évoluera avec les mêmes règles mieux
produire et protéger avec la réactivité
le dialogue et la transparence sur les
actions et les mesures vous avez évoqué
dans votre propos liminaire le nouveau
calendrier de la ploa qui a été
reconsidéré pour ajouter un volet dédié
à la simplification et d'ailleurs le
travail collaboratif avec les préfets à
d'ors et déjà a été engagé dans de
nombreux départements le mien en
particulier pouvez-vous monsieur le
ministre nous faire un point d'étape sur
les avancées des discussions avec les
professionnels et vos homologues
européens quel est le calendrier à venir
sur ces discussions et quelle suite
pourrions-nous ouvrir pour une nouvelle
session des états généraux de
l'alimentation et une nouvelle
discussion autour des plans de filière
dans un certain nombre d'entre elles
traversent des difficultés
conjoncturelle voire même structurelle
je pense à la filière bio en particulier
qui s'est mobilisée au pied de
l'Assemblée nation nationale encore
aujourd'hui merci de votre réponse
monsieur le ministre merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre euh merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre de vos de
vos questions oui l'enjeu c'est de
produire plus et mieux et d'effectuer
les transitions euh sur les mesures de
simplification on a effectivement lancé
vous avez eu raison de le rappeler je
neavais pas fait un travail sous l'git
des préfets de
département qui vise à regarder ce que
sont les réglementations départementales
qui viennent parfois s'ajouter à des
réglementations national voir des
réglementations européennes une espèce
de surtransposition
territoriale pour faire en sorte que là
où ça coince on puisse faire en sorte
qu'on ait une une forme d'harmonisation
encore que parfois il y a aussi un
mouvement inverse qui s'exprime c'est
celui de dire il faut aussi qu'on puisse
regarder territorialement la différence
conttenu des contraintes qui peuvent
être des contraintes climatiques le
travail est engagé en début de cette
semaine nous aurons des retours j'ai les
premiers retours je suis très frappé
d'une chose je voulais juste vous le
dire au passage c'est du nombre de
propositions manifestement il y avait
des gens qui attendaient compris dans
nos administrations un certain nombre de
simplification simplification c'est les
délais les procédures simplification ça
peut être les formulaires simplification
ça peut être évidemment la PAC et
simplification ça peut être parfois les
incohérences entre les réglementations
tô trop tôt aujourd'hui pour vous dire
ce sur quoi ça peut déboucher mais
l'objectif c'est bien qu'on arrive à
compiler le travail qui va être fait
sous lesgide des préfets et avec les
responsables professionnels pour
regarder là où on peut simplifier tout
de suite par voie réglementaire le faire
et là où ça nécessite un peu plus plus
de temps le faire aussi de deux points
complémentaires sur les calendriers à
venir au niveau Union européenne euh
manifestement le la commissaire
européenne la présidente de la
commission souhaite que d'ici la fin du
mois de février il puisse y avoir des
propositions nous nous tiendrons sans
doute un conseil extraordinaire il
n'était pas prévu des ministres de
l'Agriculture à la fin du mois de
février au milieu du salon ce qui va
compliquer les choses pour faire un
premier point mais enfin je crois pas
que je vais le louper celui-là enfin
j'en ai pas louper beaucoup d'ailleurs
pour faire un premier point des d'état
des simplifications et puis sur les
filières on a commencé à travailler hein
on n'est pas parti de rien je pense à la
filière fruits et légumes il faut qu'on
continue il y a un plan de filière sur
les beauvins il faut que filière par
filière on regarde là où on a besoin de
reconquérir de la souveraineté merci
merci beaucoup pour le groupe
rassemblement national c'est Hélène
Laporte qui porte la parole de ce groupe
c'est à vous merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre les récentes
annonces gouvernemental faites en
réponse au gouvernement au mouvement
historique de colère des agriculteurs
semble enfin reconnaître certaines des
revendications que nous portons depuis
des années d'une façon somm tout assez
spectaculaire nous voyons prenez
l'exacte inverse de la politique que
vous avez toujours mené vous vouliez
plus de contraintte environnementales
vous dites en vouloir moins vous vouliez
faire plus contribuer les agriculteurs
sur leur consommation de carburant vous
semblez maintenant reconnaître que c'est
de la folie vous allez même après avoir
pendant de longues années raillé le
localisme défendu par le rassemblement
national jusqu'à vouloir inscrire dans
la loi que la souveraineté alimentaire
est l'objectif central de la politique
agricole française si on ajoute une
bonbe de paille pour pupitre l'image
pourrait devenir parfaite au niveau de
la communication pourtant ces mesures
demeurent largement insuffisantes faute
d'une vraie volonté politique de rompre
avec les politiques de libre réchange
qui mettent nos producteurs en
concurrence déloyale avec les fermes
usines mondiales et de remettre en
question le carcan européen les motifs
de doute sur vos intentions sont
nombreux mais j'aimerais aujourd'hui
vous interroger sur trois points sur la
fiscalité du gazol non routier l'annonce
de l'annulation de la hausse progressif
du tarif d'asscise prévu par la loi de
finance a bien sûr été accueilli avec
soulagement nous sommes pourtant bien
obligés de rappeler que cette hausse est
inscrite dans l'agenda européen que la
France applique avec soin une réforme de
la directive de taxation de l'énergie du
27 octobre 2003 est actuellement au
projet qui pourra imposer cet alignement
de la fiscalité des carburants agricoles
voici donc ma question pour combien de
temps comptez-vous épargner nos
agriculteur de ce matraquage fiscal
souhaité par Bruxelles nous vous
demandons aussi d'être clair sur la
hausse de 2,85 € par MWh en vigueur
depuis le 1er janvier allez-vous revenir
dessus ma seconde question concernant
l'accord entre l'Union européenne et le
Mercosur malgré les déclarations de
l'exécutif sur son caractère
inacceptable il reste sur la table et de
l'aveu du vice-président de la
Commission en charge du comm commerce il
pourrait être conclu avant la fin de
l'année 2024 peut-être par le biais de
deux accords distinctes pour éviter la
règle de l'unanimité sur la partie
commerciale pouvez-vous aujourd'hui nous
assurer solennellement que la France
empêchera la conclusion de cet accord
enfin lorsque vous parlez d'en finir
avec les surtransposition vous évoquez
uniquement la législation à venir vous
ne prévoyez rien pour les innombrables
cas où nous sommes déjà en situation de
surtransposition et donc de distorsion
de concurrence entre nos agriculteurs et
leurs homologues des autres
États-membres ainsi matière
phytosanitaire il y a exactement 100
substances actives interdites par la
France alors qu'elles sont autorisées au
niveau européen sur l'acéamie Pride vous
aveit déjà affirmé qu'il était hors de
question de revenir en arrière doit-on
comprendre qu'un gouvernement qui se
veut champion dans la lutte contre les
surtranspositions ne s'attaquera à
aucune de celles qui existent
aujourd'hui faudra pourtant bien s'y
attaquer monsieur le ministre nos
agriculteurs attendent des réponses
claires et précises à ces question et
non une tir d'autosatisfaction et ou du
mépris envers vos oppositions je vous
remercie
merci Monsieur le
Ministre on peut me taxer tout SAF de
méprix je vais essayer de répondre aux
différentes questions euh aux
différentes questions qui vous sont qui
vous m'avez posé d'abord sur le GNR la
réforme est annulée la réforme est
annulée ne me parlez pas d'une
trajectoire la réforme est annulée je
sais pas comment je peux le redire dans
un dans un autre sens mais la réforme
est annulée euh et la hausse de 2,85
centimes est annulée y compris au titre
de 2024 après il faut le traduire d'un
point de vue budgétaire mais j'imagine
que vous serez saisi de textte
budgétairees dans l'année
donc on prendra les dispositions
législatives deuxième point vous
dites la simplification c'est pas non
plus le grand retour en arrière sur un
certain nombre de trajectoire pardon de
vous le dire mais vous êtes d'ailleurs
d'une région qui souffre mais la
décarbonation c'est une nécessité pour
l'agriculture et c'est une nécessité
pour l'ensemble des secteurs d'activité
économique je suis désolé de le dire
comme ça mais on a besoin de
décarbonation parce que les premières
victimes sont les agriculteurs deuxième
élément vous répondre aussi sur la
question la souveraineté alimentaire
vous c'est pas le localisme c'est pas la
même chose le localisme c'est chaque
département se nourrit ou chaque Guille
se nourrit la souveraineté alimentaire
c'est pas ça c'est de reconquérir des
pars de marché d'un point de vue
national je non attendez je vous m'en
avez fait cinq je vais bien répondre
toutes les questions 3è élément sur le
Mercosur la position de la France elle
est claire nous ne sommes pas d'accord
avec l'accord tel qu'il est posé sur la
table et manifestement ça a eu un effet
puisque l'accord n'est pas signé c'était
quand même l'intention d'un certain
nombre de gens on a besoin pardon je
vous le rappelle au niveau européen
aussi de de se trouver des alliés et
c'est le travail que nous continuons à
faire sur le sujet et puis sur les
surtranspositions j'en finis pour pas
être long puisque que j'essaie de tenir
les 4 minutes quand même sur les
surtranspositions y compris dans la les
œuvres de simplification que nous allons
faire il y a des nécessités parfois de
de lutter contre sur des sur sur des
surtranspositions sur un certain nombre
de procédures après quand il y a des
sujets de santé publique pardon madame
je vous le dis dire on revient en
arrière il y a parfois des S soci de
santé publique et nous sommes tous
comptables y compris à l'Assemblée
nationale et y compris comme
gouvernement de regarder et je
reviendrai sûrement sur les sujets tout
à l'heure donc je m'arrête là mais je
vous dirai en quoi ce que vous dites est
inexact sur la question des 100
molécules qui serait interdite en France
merci beaucoup je vous propose de passer
au groupe la France insoumise et c'est
Aurélie trouvet qui porte la parole de
son
groupe cher président collègue monsieur
le ministre alors c'est Mathilde inier
en fait qui devait prendre la parole au
nom du groupe cet après-midi mais elle
est partie sur le terrain comme vous
avez eu bon goût de lui conseiller il y
a 2 semaines pour le seul plaisir de
calomnier ma collègue qui est je le
rappelle petite fille fille
d'agriculteur et travailleuse agricole
en Bretagne mais c'est peut-être vous au
fond gouvernement qui devriez aller sur
le terrain pour vous rendre compte que
vous trahissez les revendications des
agriculteurs en colère qui vous
demandent une juste rémunération et la
protection à la place vous leur offrez
soumission et destruction soumission aux
multinationales et au chaos des marché
vos prédécesseurs vous avez tout
dérégulé depuis 25 ans les prix garantis
les quotas les droits de douanes quant à
Monsieur Macron jamais un président
n'avait autant soutenu et ratifié autant
d'accords de libre échange et il laisse
la Commission européenne poursuivre les
négociations avec le Mercosur et je vous
mets au défi monsieur le ministre de
dire le contraire peut-être le
signerez-vous le 10 juin au lendemain
des élections européennes vous soumettez
les agriculteurs au chaos des marchés en
leur vendant des broutille première
broutille les closuses miroirs qui ne
changeront rien on le sait bien au
dégâts des accords de libre échange
deème broutille d'éventuelles sanctions
qui ne changeront rien au grave
défaillance des lois Galim 3ème
broutille 50 malheureux millions d'euros
aux agriculteurs biologiques en crise on
est allé les voir cet après-midi ils
était mobilisé devant l'Assemblée
nationale vous savez ce qu'ils disent
vous les abandonn tout ce que vous
proposez aux agriculteurs c'est de
détruire leur santé notre environnement
en annonçant de très graves reculs sur
les pesticides ou sur les prairies mais
écoutez les agriculteurs en colère
vraiment ce qu'ils demandent c'est une
juste rémun gtion ça n'est pas de se
soustraire à la nécessaire transition
écologique il demande qu'on permette de
la faire en les protégeant des
multinationale et de la concurrence
internationale et c'est possible c'est
une question de volonté politique prix
rémunérateur garantie protectionnisme
écologique refus de tout nouvel accord
de libre échange activation des clauses
de sauvegarde aussi aussi souvent que
nécessaire contrat de transition
agroécologique plan de relance
alimentaire avec une restauration
collective 100 % ou alors 80 % biolocal
d'ici 5 ans voilà ce qu'il faudrait
faire mais qu'attendez-vous j'ai compris
que vous avez remisé votre loi de
désorientation agricole tant elle était
scandaleusement
vide mais je je poursuis collègue il ne
faudra pas nous vous demandons donc
évidemment une politique et une loi de
profonde transformation de l'agriculture
et de et de de protection des
agriculteurs et si ça n'est pas le cas
et bien il ne faudra pas s'étonner que
des tracteurs bloquent à nouveau nos
routes très bien merci beaucoup monsieur
monsieur le ministre merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président Madame la
Députée on peut je je n'ai pas fait
grief à votre collègue je sais très bien
qu'elle est agricultrice et ici du
milieu agricole mais on peut être issu
du milieu
agricole si vous me laissiez finir ma
phrase ça serait allez chacun va
s'écouter monsieur pas entendre de la
même façon allez-y monsieur et de toute
façon je vais faire 4 minutes vous
inquiétez pas et ne pas entendre de la
même façon les revendications des
agriculteurs j'ai vu l'ensemble des
textes que vous avez proposé à la France
insoumise c'est plus de NES plus de
contraintte dans un cadre national et
pas européen j'ai pas entendu ça je suis
désolé sur les manifestations des
agriculteurs oui vous avez raison on a
on a nécessité de travailler sur la
rémunération c'est un des éléments
fondamentaux du travail que nous avons à
faire je n'ai pas entendu non plus
quelqu'un me dire il faut arrêter
abroger égalim et revenir à la loi LME
ils nous ont demandé de faire plus
d'galimes ils nous ont demandé le porter
au niveau européen le cas échéant c'est
la question des contrôles mais c'est
aussi la question de l'évolution sur
égalim il me semble que c'est un élément
très important de le dire vous dites il
faut se replier sur nos frontières et
faire du protectionnisme madame trouvet
il va falloir aussi qu'on produise
plus parce que quand on importe 40
millions de tonnes de céréales on a un
problème on a un problème de production
sur l'espace européen et donc c'est
c'est ce bercer d'illusion que de croire
que nous n'avons pas besoin de trouver
une trajectoire qui conjugue la nité de
transition mais aussi la nécessité de
produire plus y compris au niveau
européen merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre nous passons donc au groupe les
républquain et c'est Julien DIF qui
porte la parole de son groupe merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous avez retiré le 24 dernier
janvier dernier pardon votre loi LOA qui
devitêre présenté en Conseil des
ministres et dans le même temps le
Premier ministre que ce soit le 26
janvier dans l'ode ou que ce soit sur
diverses interventions a tenu les propos
qui consistaient à préciser moins de
normes moins de moins de règles moins de
taxes et dééceté finalement libérer le
moond agricole propos que vous avez
vous-même relayé j'ai donc une question
direct dans l'avantprjet que vous aviez
prévu de présenter le 24 janvier
l'article 8 prévoyait une mise en place
d'outil de base d'outils de diagnostic
des sols clairement c'est un diagnostic
de la qualité des sols visant à évaluer
lors d'une transmission d'une
exploitation la qualité des sols pour
évaluer d'évaluer voir si on tire la
pelotte de laine pourquoi pas mettre au
contentieux l'exploitant j'aimerais
savoir donc si vous prévoyez dans la
prochain prochain texte le prochain
projet de loi qui sera présenté au
Parlement de retirer cet article 8 ou de
le maintenir cet article 8 je pense que
c'est un un sujet qui intéresse les
agriculteurs maintenant le 6 décembre
dernier lors de l'audition que nous
avions mené ici je vous avez alerté sur
la question du stockage de l'eau sur les
négociations commerciales sur le revenu
plusieurs points et et vous m'aviez
répondu avec mon et en caricature à mon
propos que j'étais adepte des grand soir
je pense que vous-même vous étiez et je
suis sûr convaincu que les agriculteurs
euh eux-mêmes attendaient ces questions
là et euh c'est pas grave la caricature
on va retirer et mettre de côté les
postures mais je voudrais savoir
Monsieur monsieur le ministre si
aujourd'hui vous êtes en phase avec cet
enjeu euh de pouvoir répondre dans la
loi d'orientation d'è agricole pas
uniquement sur la formation et la
transmission qui sont des sujets
éminemment importants mais aussi sur
tous les aspects que je viens d'évoquer
notamment l'eau les négociations
commerciales mais aussi les nouvelles
technologies et il y a quelques heures
le Parlement européen a votter une
nouvelle règle permettant l'usage dans
l'union des nouvelles techniques
génomiques et permettant du coup de
répondre aux enjeux environnementaux
êtes-vous prêt aussi à embrasser cette
voie merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
je commence peut-être par le dernier
point NBT NGT nous avons toujours été en
soutien des NBT
NGT nous avons demandé un certain nombre
de choses la première qui a été
d'ailleurs auquelle il a été donné droit
c'est de faire en sorte qu'elle vienne
bien servir un objectif de réduction
d'usage des produits phytosanitaires
pour sortir des impasse mais vous
connaissez le sujet aussi bien que moi
dans lequel se trouve un certain nombre
de cultures et deuxième élément que ces
technologies
permettent d'avoir des plantes qui
soient plus résilientes au dérèglement
climatiqu et en particulier le sujet
stress hydrique mais il y a aussi le
sujet stress thermique qu'on évoque
assez peu d'ailleurs mais qui est un
vrai sujet pour un certain nombre de
productions et donc moi je me félicite
du vote du Parlement euréen c'est
moi-même avec plusieurs collègues qui
avion poussé le collègue espagnol qui é
présidé à faire en sorte qu'il soit mis
dans le calendrier du dernier semestre
2023 j'ai revu mon collègue berge la
semaine dernière pour lui dire que nous
étions prêts à
engager résolument les choses pour qu'on
puisse obtenir ces ces technologie on a
un petit sujet c'est que nous n'avons
pas aujourd'hui une majorité qualifiée
au niveau européen donc le travail que
nous avons à faire c'est un travail de
conviction avec quelques collègues que
je vais m'employer à convaincre sur le
sujet deuxième élément sur la question
fondamentale de du diagnostic des des
sol on a besoin je le dis de travailler
sur la question des sols on sait qu'une
partie y compris de la productivité elle
est liée à une dégradation des sols il y
a pas de grille à face faire mais on
sait c'est constaté la baisse de la
matière organique l'usure des sols c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que les techniques de
travail simplifiés sont fort utiles on a
besoin d'avoir quelque chose et un
travail collectif sur ce sujet-là on va
faire évoluer le dispositif pour d'abord
ne pas le rendre obligatoire mais que
celui qui s'interroge comme il
s'interroge sur son modèle climatique il
puisse s'interroger dans sa productivité
sur la nature du sol sur lequel il va
travailler ce que j'ai généralement
d'ailleurs les agriculteurs font mais
dans le modèle qu'on a travaillé il faut
travailler là-dessus et puis dernier
point globalement sur oui nous avons
besoin de travailler alors j'avais
répondu d'ailleurs sur la question des
revenus sur le fait que c'était dans Gal
mais l'objectif c'est bien l'application
de la loi tirait exemple de ce qui se
fera dans les dans les travaux
parlementaires pour regarder les
évolutions législatives et ça ça reste
sur la table comme je crois j'avais dû
vous répondre sur les négociations
commerciales là aussi c'est un travail
alors je sais pas si c'est une affaire
de grand soir monsieur div je persiste à
penser que tout ne se résout pas en un
soir et tout ne se résout pas en un
texte voyz bien qu'il y a des sujets
européens et qu' a des sujets sur les
pratiques commerciales qui doivent
évoler et qu'on a un débat à voir avec
citoyens consommateurs sur la question
du Juste Prix du juste coû et donc du
Juste Prix donc peut-être êtvous plus
révolutionnaire que moi mais en tout cas
je reprends ce que je crois j'avais dit
à l'époque mais c'était pas méchant me
semble-il est pas très agressif même à
l'époque merci donc on a besoin de
travailler mais il y a des sujets court
terme des sujet plus long terme merci
beaucoup pour le groupe démocrate c'est
qui porte la parole du
groupe
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre nous avons vécu ces dernières
semaines la colère de nos agriculteurs
nous connaissons les enjeux majeurs
résoudre la question du revenu agricole
mais aussi du renouvellement des
générations le groupe démocrate tient à
saluer votre engagement depuis le début
de votre exercice et durant cette
période difficile tant sur le terrain
que dans les médias pour relayer les
problématiques de la profession et les
enjeux qui nous attend par ailleurs je
me réjouis que le gouvernement a
réaffirmé la nécessité de respecter les
lois égalim dans la sanctuirisation des
matières premières
agricoles et notamment dans les
contrôles un autre volet desal mérite
d'être mis en en lumière et en
application la loi définit des objectifs
de produits locaux et bio dans la
restauration collective nous ne sommes
pas au rendez-vous afin de répondre aux
objectifs il nous faut structurer des
filières en local malgré la volonté
exprimere des territoires on ne peut que
constater les difficultés de mise en
place des projets alimentaires
territoriaux il existe une problématique
de gouvernance une nécessité d'apporter
un ad clair au territoire avec une
planification des engagements et des
actions et de définir des indicateurs de
mesure les collectivités sont aussi
contrainte par le code de la commande
publique vous l'avez compris il existe
de nombreux freins à lever les Pat sont
un outil de transition qui permettra de
renforcer notre souveraineté alimentaire
et permettra par ailleurs d'aider à long
terme la filière bio aujourd'hui en
grande difficulté j'aimerais connaître
votre avis sur le sujet je vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
merci madame la députée babo sur sujets
qui tournent notamment autour des Galim
bon il y a égalim sur la partie
rémunération négociation commerciale et
c'est vrai qu'il y a un pan sur lequel
on a pas avancé collectivement assez qui
est le pan de la du respect de ce qui
avait été voté par les parlementaires
c'était en 200 en 2018 Stéphan travers
on souvient parfaitement pour faire en
sorte qu'on puisse intégrer plus de
produits Bio et plus de produits locaux
d'abord pour la part de l'État parce
qu'avant de donner des conseils en tout
cas je me garderais bien de donner des
leçons pour la part de l'État l'objectif
en 2020 c'est que nous soyons
rendez-vous dans toutes les
administrations de l'État c'est à peu
près 100 millions d'euros hein de surcût
de la loi égalim et que nous respections
les 20 et 30 enfin les 50 % de produits
bio et locaux pour faire simple c'est un
sujet qui est très important deuxième
élément nous avons puissamment
accompagné les Pat dans le plan de
relance 80 millions d'Uros 170 Pat nous
avons des moyens qui sont prévus aussi
pour les consolider parce que ça fait
partie des sujets dans le projet de loi
de finances voté de 2024 et nous avons
besoin de continuer à à accompagner les
territoires et puis moi je vais vous le
dire je le dis aussi comme élu local et
je fais la son à personne le sujet de
l'alimentation et la du choix
d'alimentation qu'on fait c'est un choix
de collectivité locale aussi il
m'appartient pas non plus de me
substituer je peux juste dire nous avons
et nous avons des collectivités locales
au niveau régional ou niveau
départemental ou infra c'est-à-dire dans
le bloc communal qui respecte la loi
égaling ça n'est pas le cas de beaucoup
d'entre elles alors j'entends parfois
des responsables de collectivité dire
donner des leçons à l'état sur qu'est-ce
qu'on fait pour l'agriculture si nous
faisions
simplement ce que ce qui est écrit dans
la loi sur le bio nous n'aurions pas de
crise du bio c'est aussi simple que cela
et donc on a un travail à reprendre avec
les collectivités locales pour dire vous
avez des choix
politiques les politiques publiques
c'est de faire des choix entre
différentes arbitrage qu'on a à faire
parce que les budgets sont pas non plus
extensibles mais c'est de faire en sorte
aussi que si on pense que l'alimentation
a une valeur si c'est a un intérêt en
terme de santé publique si on pense que
ça un intérêt en terme de décarbonation
si on pense que ça un intérêt en en
terme de transition on a besoin que les
politiques publiques s'alignent et donc
on va faire un travail alors on a un
travail aussi en faire encore dans le
domaine hospitalier pour vous dire les
choses et puis un travail à faire avec
les collectivités là ça rel plutôt du
registre de l'état mais on a un travail
à faire aussi avec les collectivités
locales pour les encourager et donner
l'exemple il y a une plateforme à
cantine qui vise à montrer à donner
l'exemple il faut qu'on pousse chacune
et chacun à prendre ses responsabilités
sur le
sujet merci beaucoup je propose de
passer au groupe socialiste et c'est
Dominique petier qui
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre euh nous avons le sentiment
très fort et et c'est pour nous on est
c'est une grande désolation c'est qu'on
a une sortie de crise par le bas je vais
essayer de vous donner quelques pistes
d'analyse et et de dialogue pour qu'on
construise ensemble une sortie par le
haut tout d'abord une explication sur ce
qui a été au cœur de la crise l'accord
sur le GNR l'accord fiscal qui l'a
conduit et comment est-ce que vous êtes
responsable de cet accord et pourquoi
l'avez-vous fait il était
particulièrement unique il a été révélé
à l'occasion de cette crise sur
l'agriculture biologique qui vit une
crise extrêmement profonde est-ce
qu'au-delà des aides publiques au-delà
des 50 millions annoncés est-ce qu'il y
a des mécanismes européens de régulation
des marchés de dégagement des marchés
qui peuvent s'imposer pour sauver une
filière qui est une promesse pour nos
territoires et pour la planète sur
écofito deux questions monsieur le
ministre où est la ministre de la Santé
vous n'avez pas cité dans le plan la
réunion du COS qui va se réunir la
semaine prochaine je pense que c'est
un oubli mais son silence est
assourdissant dans la pause qui a été
proclamée alors que c'est un enjeu
d'abord de santé publique et en premier
lieu pour nos agriculteurs vous avez
dans la communication gouvernementale
ces derniers temps fait un
rebasage des résultats d'une au ne nous
faites pas le coup en plus du changement
d'indicateur pour pour tromper tout le
monde il y a un enjeu d'indicateur
européen mais en aucun cas il doit être
inférieur à l'exigence qui a été décrit
notamment par la commission d'enquête
que nous avons mené ensemble vous avez
annoncé des mesures mur fiscal pour la
transmission pouvez-vous nous
transmettre les études d'impact qui ont
précédé ces mesures quel décil de
richesse d'agriculteur concerern-t-il je
suis effaré par les chiffres que j'ai vu
j'aimerais qu'il serent vraiment à
l'installation hors succession et sur
l'ensemble des
agricultures le groupe socialiste a
déposé une proposition de résolution
avec des signés par 70 députés de 7
groupes différents qui proposent que les
mesures miroir ne soient pas des miroirs
aux alouettes mais qu'elle soi effective
avez-vous pris connaissance de cette
proposition de résolution entendez-vous
la défense à l'échelle européenne enfin
sur les questions des galimes vous avez
aujourd'hui tout a été dit sur les Galim
est ce qu'il fallit faire sur é Galim la
crise avait un angle mort c'est
l'agroourniture êtes-vous prêt à
envisager comme nous le proposons une
extension par la modification du code
rural d'émission de l'Observatoire à des
prix pour qu'il explore non seulement
l'aval mais l'amont de l'agriculture je
vous remercie merci Monsieur le
Ministre merci beaucoup merci Monsieur
potier
nous aussi on souhaite une sortie par le
haut et vous m'avez jamais entendu dans
mes propos essayer de dégrader les
choses tel que vous le décrivez donc je
suis pas du tout d'accord avec vous sur
mais on peut pas à longueur de temps
dire on veut pas de
surtransposition attendez et passer son
temps à dire on veut des
surtranspositions je vous donne un seul
exemple sur
l'indicateur si l'Europe décide d'une
trajectoire de réduction c'est pas mal
que ça soit fait au niveau européen
quand même c'est quand même mieux qu'on
ait le même indicateur
non plus exig parce que sinon on est en
train de porter des exigences que qui
vont peser plus sur nos agriculteurs que
sur les voisins allemand espagnol ou
italien pardon de vous dire que on peut
trouver un indicateur qui permette
d'encourager les efforts sur les
produits qui sont les plus à risque
santé environnement ou autre sans que ce
soit le dévoiement d'une volonté
politique et publ de réduction des
produits phytosanitaires mais si
l'Europe dit alors j'ai bien entendu ce
qu'a dit la présidente van der sur le
règlement sûr elle a dit je retire le
texte cont tenu du fait
que manifestement ça pose un problème
pas qu'en France Monsieur potier ça pose
un problème dans l'Europe tout entière C
cette affaire de sû en disant on va
remettre les elle a dit elle a dit dans
la même phrase on va remettre les
parties prenantes autour de la table
pour faire en sorte qu'on puisse y
répondre à cette injonction
contradictoire qui était vécu au travers
du règlement sûr si on a un règlement
sûr un jour qui vient et qu'on dit la
trajectoire c'est celle-là vaut mieux
qu'on ait le même indicateur et donc on
a besoin de travailler sur des
indicateurs sur la question la
proposition de résolution j'en ai pris
connaissance après on va regarder
comment ça peut se traduire mais vous
savez bien que sur les mesures miroires
il faut qu'on ait quand même un accord
des pays européens donc il y a une
bataille européenne à mener mais
reconnaissez avec moi que le premier
pays qui a posé la question des clauses
miroir c'est la France enfin dernier
point et j'en finis sur les mesures
fiscales de sa transmission évidemment
quand il y aura les éléments précisément
posés sur la table vous aurez le droit à
des éléments d'analyse sur les les
l'impact de ces mesures y compris sur la
question de la transmission l'objectif
du gouvernement c'est pas qu'il y ait
des des et de ben c'est bien qu'on ait
plus d'agriculteurs qui
s'installent bien merci beaucoup je vous
propose de passer au groupe horizon et
c'est Thierry Benoît qui porte la parole
du groupe c'est à vous merci monsieur le
ministre dans le prolongement de la
mobilisation des jours passé et parmi
des sujets qui restent en suspens il y a
en effet l'agriculture bio vous vous
avez annoncé 50 millions supplémentaires
qui abondent les 100 millions initiaux
ce qui pent le montant des soutiens à
100 50 millions lorsqu'on écoute les
interprofessions animales ou végétales
lorsqu'on écoute l'Agence Bio ou la
fédération nationale du BU eux leur
estimation elle se porte entre 250 et
300 millions ça me fait penser au débat
sur les maices donc très vite il va
falloir cerner le besoin exact pour
venir en soutien le deuxième point dans
l'esprit de ce qu'a dit le précédent
orateur et c'est sur la proposition de
certains acteurs bio est-ce qu'il y a
pas à mettre en place des outils de
retrait de plusieurs productions animal
et végétal du bio pour relancer la
filière parce que le bio en ce moment le
la production ne trouve pas son marché
donc il y a des stocks qui s'empilent et
il faut à la fois comme vous l'avez dit
agir sur la restauration collective agir
aussi auprès de la grande distribution
qui à un moment donné a été tenté de
faire des marges disproportionné ce qui
a sans doute aussi contribué à ralentir
le marché donc outil de retrait des
stocks sur la restauration collective
dans l'esprit de la loi 3DS il me semble
qu'il y avait un décret qui devait être
pris pour simplifier clarifier le rôle
éducation nationale et des collectivités
territoriales dans la composition des
menus pour atteindre les fameux 20 % de
bio enfin sur la politique agricole
commune 2022- 2025 est-ce que nous en
France on ne pourrait pas réouvrir le
dossier pilier 1 pilier 2 moins d'aide
aux surfaces agricoles plus plus d'aide
aux actifs agricoles plus d'aide à
l'élevage et plus d'aide finalement euh
aux prairies parce que lorsqu'il y a
d'élevage il y a des
prairies merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre merci euh Monsieur Benoît je
prends deux sujets principaux vous avez
fait bio et PAC hein on va essayer de
prendre ces deux sujets dans les 2
minutes qui me reste oui c'est de même
nature le que le débat que nous avions
vu que vous aviez soulevé sur la
question des Mac je je rappelle mais
c'est pas vous qui l'aviez porté que
j'ai vu un amendement à 500 millions
d'euros hein
et qu la vérité c'est que le besoin
n'était pas à 500 million d'euros donc
je je me défie toujours des chiffres
qu'on annonce et qu'on aligne sans que
ce soit tout à fait documenté et donc je
et comme vous le savez on a donné droit
aux demandes on a trouvé les vois et
moyens pour donner droit aux demandes et
nous n'étions pas dans ces étiages là
par rapport à ce qui manquait sur ces
questions des ma mais c'est un élément
juste que je veux dire on va réunir la
filière bio pour voir les filières qui
sont plus en risque aujourd'hui
deuxièmement et donc pour regarder dans
l'urgence ce qu'on peut ce qu'on peut
faire sur ces filières les plus à risque
et continuer à travailler avec eux pour
pour voir s'il y a besoin de mesures
complémentaires ça n'est pas fermé j'ai
besoin qu'on documente les choses et
qu'on le fasse en bon ordre l'objectif
est le principal pour moi étant que le
ceux qui sont converti ne se
déconvertissent pas la la relance de la
consommation c'est après pour le moyen
long terme on a besoin de travailler au
niveau européen j'entends ce que vous
dites sur les mesures de retrait la
vérité c'est que le consommateur
européen n'a pas tout à fait les mêmes
les mêmes réflexe je parle avec mon
collègue autrichien ils ont pas de
baisse de consommation du bio pourquoi
parce que la grande distribution a joué
de jeu y compris en terme d'exposition
des produits donc on a besoin aussi avec
la grande distribution au-delà de ce
qu'on fait sur égalim et sur les
contrôles de dire si vous soutenez le
bio il faut le soutenir tout le temps et
c'est notment dans la période de crise
qu'il faut le soutenir et pas simplement
par effet d'opportunité ou
d'opportunisme me semble-t-il parce que
le le la la la la les choses se font
différemment après sur la question de la
PAC c'est un un débat que vous
connaissez bien parce que c'est un vieux
débat c'est le débat entre le premer et
le deuxème pilier reconnaiss les
services environnementaux oui alors
paiement pour services environnementaux
c'est un travail qu'on doit faire y
compris euh parce que c'est pas tout à
fait ce qui était prévu dans la pack
2022 2024 y compris dans le règlement de
base on a un travail à faire sur 2027
dans l'intervalle on aura une clause de
revoyure à 2025 sur la PAC c'est le
moment de réouvrir cette boîte là et de
se poser ces questionsl mais vous voyez
bien que c'est un équilibre qui est très
difficile à tenir et qui fait que dès
que vous glissez d'un pilier vers
l'autre évidemment vous avez des
récriminations d'un territoire vers
l'autre et donc il faut qu'on essaie de
trouver un point d'équilibre à terme
2027 se posera cette questionl mais de
savoir d'ailleurs si le paiement pour
services environnementaux il relève de
la pack ou il relève d'autre choses
merci beaucoup je vous propose de passer
au groupe écologiste et c'est la
ministre Delphine bateau qui porte la
parole du groupe merci monsieur le
Président le degré de certitude d'ors et
déjà acquis sur les effets des produits
phytopharmaceutique commande de prendre
des mesures fortes et rapides sauf à
engager la responsabilité des pouvoirs
publics écrivez des inspecteurs de de
votre ministère en décembre 2017
conjointement avec des inspecteurs du
ministère de l'écologie et du ministère
de la Santé manière pour ses
fonctionnaires d'alerter de dire qu'ils
ont pris eux leur responsabilité et que
la responsabilité est désormais
politique ma question porte donc sur
l'état de droit puisque la notion
d'objectif de réduction des pesticides
est dans la loi vous la mettez
aujourd'hui en pause et vous souhaitez
casser le thermomètre en trafiant les
indicateurs et au pesticides tout y
passe et en fait ce reniment vient de
loin l'échec du plan écofito était déjà
éloquent et le tournant avait commencé
avec le renoncement à l'interdiction du
glyphosate et la loi réautorisant les
néonicotines les néonicotinoïdes nous
assistons au holdup des firmes de
l'agrochimie dont vous vous faites les
serviteurs ciles sur les revendications
des agricultrices et des agriculteurs
que nous soutenons qu'est-ce qu'ils nous
ont dit sur les barrages et les
rond-points le ministère de
l'Agriculture me doit 38000 €
d'indemnisation grippe aviaère le
ministère de l'Agriculture a réduit
l'enveloppe MAE de la région
poitoucharante le ministère de
l'Agriculture me doit 48000 € d'aide
alors que je suis agriculteur biologique
dans les camions ici circule du persil
du Venezuela des kioui du Portugal des
poulets du Brésil dénonçant les accords
de libre échange que vous avez soutenu
et que nous avons combattu il et elle
remettent en cause un modèle
productiviste qui sème la misère dans
les fermes la faim dans les ventres à
l'autre bout de la chaîne la profitation
entre les deux qui détruit la nature
tout autant que les femmes et les hommes
qui sont des travailleuses et des
travailleurs de la terre la colère du
monde paysan que nous avons entendu et
soutenu sur les barrages et les
ronds-points ne demandait pas une
politique d'empoisonnement alimentaire
par contre oui ils exigent de la
cohérence la cohérence ce qui était par
exemple proposé par nos amendements 1453
ou 897 lors de la loi égalim proposant
d'interdire la l'importation et la
commercial isation de produits traités
avec des pesticides interdits dans
l'Union européenne et en France monsieur
le ministre vous êtes en responsabilité
ma question est donc simple êtes-vous
prêt à assumer la responsabilité des
conséquences en termees de santé
publique et d'effondrement de la
biodiversité du renoncement du Premier
ministre à la sortie des pesticides je
parle de la responsabilité politique
civile mais on sait aussi qu'elle
peut-être pénale car si pour l'instant
la justice a établi le préjudice
écologique et la carence fautive de
l'État dans l'effondrement de la
biodiversité et la pollution de l'eau
résultant du non respect du plan écyo
demain il se pourrait que ce soit la
justice pénale qui soit saisie merci
Monsieur le Ministre oui merci monsieur
le Président Madame la Députée
bateau chacun doit prendre sa
responsabilité sur la stratégiecopyo
vous avez vous-même être été ministre de
l'écologie donc je trouve que cette
façon de rejeter en permanence sur le
suivant des choses qui n'ont pas été
réglées par les précédents c'est
sympathique
mais parfois c'est un peu lassant
2uxième élément aucun moment vous n'avez
entendu dire que la stratégie de
réduction des produits phytosanitaires
n'était pas la stratégie du gouvernement
à quel moment vous avez entendu ça
madame bateau prendre quelques semaines
et pardon je vous lis juste que dit une
des recommandation du rapport de la
commission d'enquête de Monsieur
potier améliorer la pertinence et la
réactivité des indicateurs de mesure des
produits
phytosanitair deuxièmement soutenir
l'adoption d'un indicateur européen pas
non mais soutenir l'adoption d'un
indicateur européen alors on peut on
peut le faire dans tous les sens vous
dites exactement la même chose que ce
que je vous dis
ici et donc on a besoin dans le travail
qu'on a faire sur écofito de le faire
dans ce registre là il me semble que
c'est un élément important et puis je
finis juste monsieur le Président pour
dire une chose la France c'est sans
doute le pays en terme de cmr1 et cmmr2
qui a le plus réduit l'usage de ces
produits là plus de 90 % pour l'un plus
de 80 % pour l'autre si on se donnait
aussi quand même des des des gages du
fait qu'on a avancé sur ces sujets là
plutôt qu'on a reculer et j'aimerais
bien qu'on fasse une comparaison avec
les autres pays européens pour voir où
en sont les autres mais pour le coup on
est très en avance par rapport à
d'autres merci beaucoup je propose de
passer au groupe GDR et c'est le
président André chassigne qui prend la
parole pour le
groupe votre micro merci bon face à la
crise monsieur le ministre le
gouvernement a apporté des réponses en
urgence qui peuvent calmer au premier
degré ou plutôt selon moi qui donne
l'illusion d'une colère donée
certes il a par exemple la m sous
tutelle d'organisation comme l'ofb il y
a le plan écofyo en pause il y a le
soutien ponctuel à la viticulture et au
bio en fait des mesures qui constituent
un 1è plan d'urgence guerre différent
des précédent vous y ajoutez la
simplification par voie réglementaire
mais jusqu'où cette simplification peut
aller ce qui m'amène au cœur du débat
que je voudrais poser vous avez parlé de
brèche dansun dialogue européen pour ma
part je suis extrêmement dubitatif quant
à la possibilité que vous avez de briser
le plafond de verre d'une politique
agricole européenne qui est extrêmement
libérale qui s'appuie sur la concurrence
qui s'appuie sur la compétitivité est-ce
que vous pensez que dans les
négociations qui sont en cours il va y
avoir une véritable réorientation de la
politique agricole commune s'il y a pas
cette réorientation de la politique
agricole commune la colère restera
est-ce que par exemple les plans
stratégiques nationaux tels que celui
qui est appliqué aujourd'hui en France
est-ce que ces plans stratégiques
nationaux vous allez être conduit à les
réformer en profondeur je dis bien en
profondeur au regard des insuffisances
qui vont qu'il commencent à manifester
et ce qui m'amène à dire que le fond du
problème et c'est ce qui manque
aujourd'hui ce sont des réformes
structurelles c'est la question ça a été
dit de la juste rémunération que l'État
intervienne non seulement dans la
détermination du prix de de 20 mais
aussi dans la répartition de la valeur
ajoutée sur la chaîne de sur l'ensemble
de la chaîne de valeur construire une
économie agricole régulé avec des outils
mort l'État pour le moment s'est
toujours refusé est-ce que vous allez
prendre à bras le corp cette question
deuxièmement la question des accords
commerciaux ou de libre échange bon vous
le pouvoir féminine de temporiser et
d'agir au plan européen notamment sur
les négociations avec le Mercosur mais
de fait il n'y a aucune remise en cause
des grandes orientations en faveur de la
libération des échanges on est d'accord
pour qu'il a des échanges commerciaux y
compris dans le domaine dans le domaine
alimentaire à condition que ça soit dans
le respect des peuples dans le respect
des territoires ça crée pas des
déséquilibres ça c'est c'est extrêmement
important mais c'est pas le cas des
accords des accords de libre échange il
faut revoir de font en comble la
politique commerciale concernant
l'agriculture il faut sortir
l'alimentation des échanges commerciaux
voilà je pense que sans réformes
structurelles profonde et ben on ne
résoudra pas le problème
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre euh
merci merci euh monsieur le Président
merci monsieur le Président chassigne je
je vais aller juste sur le sujet
principal que vous avez évoqué c'est il
y a un besoin d'un changement profond
vous disz il y a besoin de changer
profondément la politique agricole
commune je pense qu'il y a d'abord
besoin de changer radicalement la
politique commerciale européenne parce
que c'est de là que vont découler le
reste des choses parce qu'on peut
toujours faire la politique agricole
commune qu'on veut si on a des règles
commerciales qui ne correspondent pas
aux attentes que vous exprimez que je
partage pour un certain nombre d'entre
elles ça n'ira pas et il y a deux sujets
sur la question de la politique
commerciale c'est de faire en sorte que
si l'agriculture est bien un objet de
souveraineté au même titre que l'énergie
au même titre que les médicaments au
même titre que les les les technologies
de pointe alors à ce moment-là ça peut
pas être l'objet d'un troc dans le cadre
des accords commerciaux et c'est ce qui
s'est passé depuis 30 ans c'est
exactement ça ce qui s'est passé donc il
y a un changement de philosophie c'est
sur la pile des choses importantes la
pile agricole et donc c'est un un
changement profond de la politique
commerciale européenne qu'il faut amener
et à partir de là de travailler sur une
politique agricole commune qui vienne
s'aligner sur ces objectifs làà et je
partage le sentiment que vous avez équé
c'est il faut des échanges mais il faut
des échanges on peut pas dire à la fois
il y a une exception alimentaire et en
même temps on on accepte les échanges
une partie de la puissance agricole
européenne et je le dis ici comme je
l'ai déjà dit il est important qu'on
puisse se
nourrir y compris dans un contexte de
dérèglement climatique qui va
singulièrement compliquer les choses il
est important aussi qu'on sache qui
nourrit nos voisinage parce que je n'ai
pas envie de laisser à Monsieur Poutine
par exemple le soin de nourrir notre
voisinage parce que c'est une question
de souveraineté par la souveraineté
alimentaire c'est la souveraineté tout
court qu'on essaie de régler et donc
c'est ça aussi qu'il faut essayer de
régler et donc il me semble qu'on doit
pouvoir mais c'est le sujet central pour
moi c'est le sujet de la politique
commerciale européenne mais nous avons
commencé au travers des mesures miroires
même si on est très loin encore de ce
que on doit atteindre merci beaucoup je
vous propose de terminer nos orateurs de
groupe avec le groupe y et c'est David
topiaak qui porte la parole de son
groupe merci Monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre vous allez
présenter la future loi d'orientation
agricole en conseil des ministres au
moment du Salon International de
l'Agriculture allez-vous nous associer
d'ici là en tant que parlementaire au
contact du terrain nous avons des
propositions à faire et nous redoutons
que vous fassiez des impasses sur des
sujets importants que nous avons déjà
évoqué tels que la transmission et
l'accès au fonciers vous avez annoncé
inscrire l'impératif de souveraineté
alimentaire dans la loi c'est un
objectif auquel nous souscrivons B il ne
suffit pas de le décréter pour le voir
s'appliquer d'autant qu'il est déjà
présent dans notre code de l'agriculture
alors qu'allez-vous proposer
concrètement nous le savons notre
agriculture souffre d'une concurrence
déloyale un agriculteur chez moi dans l'
Gers me disait juste titre qui
achèterait chez nous une voiture qui ne
serait pas au standard européen de
sécurité et environnementaux nous avons
trop longtemps accepté d'importer des
produits qui ne respectent pas nos
règles environnementales et sanitaires
cela fait des années que les
agriculteurs réclame des clauses miroirs
dans les traités de libre échange et des
années que le gouvernement promet de se
saisir de la question où en sommes-nous
des négociation européennees sur ce
point un mot enfit sur la transition
agroécologique un cap que nous devons
conserver collectivement et nous nous
n'y parviendrons qu'à condition de
garantir à nos agriculteurs des revenus
suffisants en cela nous regrettons les
aides insuffisantes à la filière bio
vous avez promis 50 millions d'euros
nous avions évoquer le nécessité d'un
budget de 271 millions d'euros euh
évalué avec la filière et déposé dans le
cadre du débat budgétaire des un
amendement que j'avais d'ailleurs fait
voter avant que le 493
n'intervienne des améliorations sont
nécessaires en outre s'agissant de
l'adaptation des règlements climatiques
la réforme de l'assurance récolte je
vous l'ai déjà évoqué en décembre lors
d'un débat ne tient pas ses promesses le
nombre de souscription reste bas et le
mécanisme de la moyenne olympique ne
permet plus de de couvrir de façon
satisfaisante les exploitations sur ces
sujets également nous attendons des
réponses enfin pour terminer monsieur le
ministre je suis alerté par la
viticulture gersoise 25 millions d'euros
sont nécessaires dans le gerse pour
faire face au mil duw nous en aurons
finalement C sur les 80 annoncés
toujours sous la règle des minimi qui
reste souspoudrage et rend le dispositif
inapplicable et injuste pour les
viticulteurs
monsieur le
ministre merci beaucoup beaucoup de
questions alors d'abord pour dire les
choses clairement vous avez été reçu au
ministère y compris à mon niveau sur la
question du ploa et on va continuer à
faire ce travail d'ici le texte tel que
modifié tel que je vous le dis et donc à
ce moment-là vous pourra vous présenter
parce qu'on est en cours de rédaction
quand même les les éléments qui sont les
éléments importants deuxème deuxè sujet
sur le calendrier c'est l'idée c'est
qu'on puisse envoyer au Conseil d'État à
la fin du mois de février c'est pas au
Conseil des ministres il y a une
procédure qui est Conseil d'État puis
Conseil des ministres mais qu'au moins
au moment du salon on puisse faire en
sorte que les choses soient posées sur
la table 3ième élément de réponse vous
parlez des clauses miroir pardon il y a
3 ans personne ne savait même ce qui
était une clause miroire ça n'était pas
du tout sur la table et c'est la France
qui l'a mis sur la
table sous cette forme là dans les
débats commerciaux ça n'était pas posé
comme ça sur la
table donc le fait qu'on a pu inclure y
compris dans l'accord du
CTA un certain nombre de premières
clauses miroire la difficulté maintenant
le travail que nous avons à faire c'est
un travail répondant faisant écho à ce
qu'a dit le président Chassagne c'est de
faire en sorte que nous puissions dans
l'ensemble des accords qui vont être
signés ou qui sont en négociation
inclure les clauses miroir en
particulier sur les sujets climatiques
mais pas que sur les sujets climatiques
enfin dernier point sur l'assurance
récolte je peux pas vous dire laisser
dire on va réunir les les assureurs et
l'ensemble des acteurs agricoles il y a
plus 36 % de surface agricole qui sont
couvertes par l'assurance récolte grâce
à ce mécanisme ça veut pas dire qu'il
est parfait ça veut juste dire qu'il
s'est passé quelque chose sur
l'arbculture on est passé de tête de 1,2
ou 3 % à 10 % ça veut pas dire que c'est
parfait enfin la trajectoire nous sommes
largement audessus de la trajectoire
budgétaire que nous avions prévu dans
les le triénal on a besoin d'ajuster
mais ne faisons pas d'une réussite
quelque chose qui serait un échec de
votre
part merci beaucoup je propose de passer
maintenant aux questions individuelles
et nous avons beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de questions monsieur le ministre à ce
stade 22 intervenants Éric Gérardin
Aurélien Lopez Ligouri roné Pilato
Jérome nur éic Martine Charles Fournier
Patrice Perro Mathias Tavel Martine
Froget Nicole LEP Christophe bartes
ériic botorel Francis dubis Grégoire de
for sopia Chikirou Delphine bateau Anne
lorblin Timothé housoussin Sylvain
carrière Vincent descœur Nicolas maison
Aurélie Trouvé si votre nom n'a pas été
cité levez la main on va arriver à la
demi-heure de question monsieur le
ministre je crainte de ne pas pouvoir
tenir l'heure et demi donc nous
commençons tout de suite donc levez bien
la main et on va vous noter et on
commence tout de suite avec Sofia
Chikirou allez-y je serai intraitable
sur la minute hein pour tous hein je le
dis parce que là on il faut accé merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président du coup
je vais aller très très vite monsieur le
ministre la Fédération nationale de
l'agriculture biologique a manifesté
aujourd'hui devant l'Assemblée nationale
nous sommes allés à leur rencontre
l'agriculture bio c'est 14 % des fermes
200000 emplois 0 % de chimie de synthèse
et plus 30 % de biodiversité dans les
fermes bio au moment de la loi des
finances nous avons voté nous les
parlementaire 270 millions d'euros
d'aide au bio 300 millions d'aidees
agroenvironnemental vous avez tout
effacé avec le 493 et aujourd'hui vous
leur avez concédé 50 millions d'euros
pauvrees 50 pauvres millions d'euros ma
question est simple comptez-vous aider
le bio à se développer dans notre pays
sachant qu'il porte la transition
écologique ou comptez-vous les sacrifier
face à votre incapacité en réalité à
faire respecter par exemple les 20 % de
bio dans les cantines merci Aurélien
Lopez ligori
monsieur le ministre à l'heure où notre
agriculture défaille il n'existe
aujourd'hui aucune obligation pour les
cantines scolair de prioriser des
produits français cette situation est au
mieux absurde au pire catastrophique euh
pour cela le levier de la commande
publique qui est capitale prioriser les
produits français dans les cantines
c'est à la fois soutenir nos
agriculteurs et éduquer notre jeunesse à
bien manger équilibré et local et encore
faut-il pouvoir le faire euh vous
promettez des quotas de produits
nationaux ce que disait monsieur hatal
dans les cantines très bien encore une
victoire idéologique du rassemblement
national puisque cela fait maintenant 10
ans qu'on en parle mais plus que les
mots maintenant les actes vous le savez
ces annonces sont contraires au droit de
la concurrence de l'Union européenne
donc ma question est simple pour la
santé de nos enfants pour la défense de
nos agriculteurs quand remettrez-vous
enfin en cause les le droit de la
concurrence de l'Union et comment
ferez-vous sans accepter de renégocier
les traités merci merci Monsieur René
Pilato
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre à propos de la souveraineté
alimentaire je reprends vos propos sur
la chaîne C news je vous cite la
souveraineté alimentaire c'est quoi
c'est pas l'autarsie c'est pas
l'autosuffisance la souveraineté
alimentaire c'est que nous décidions que
sur un certain nombre de filières où
nous sommes déficitaires fruits et
légumes au vin d'autres filières nous
fassions en sorte de reconquérir cette
souveraineté la souveraineté alimentaire
c'est plus de production française pour
avoir plus de produits français la
souveraineté alimentaire c'est la
capacité à reprendre notre destin en
main en matière de production agricole
la souveraineté c'est une souveraineté
générale c'est devenu une arme de guerre
j'ai besoin d'une souveraineté qui
permette de rayonner à travers le monde
là monsieur le ministre vous avez perdu
totologie sophisme et banalité selon moi
c'est quand même l'autosuffisance à
l'objectif intérieur ma question est
claire pour être éclairée si selon vous
la souveraineté n'est pas
l'autosuffisance quel est votre votre
définition vis-à-vis des traités de
libre échange merci Monsieur Jérôme
Nurit
mon Jérôme nu n'est pas là mais Pierre
Vatin est là très bien
allez-y merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je voudrais que
vous reveniez sur le décret curage
j'aimerais bien que vous nous éclairiez
un petit peu parce que les choses vont
s'articuler entre d'une part les
agriculteurs ou les maires et d'autre
part l'ofb sachant que jusqu'à
aujourd'hui les menaces pénales étaient
plus dissuasive que la nécessité
d'assurer un entretien courant d'un
fossé ou d'un cour d'eau pour lequel
l'autorisation d'intervention était
particulièrement restrictive j'aimerais
que vous nous expliquiez un petit peu
comment aujourd'hui les choses vont
s'articuler sur ce sujet merci merci
beaucoup et désolé j'avais marqué enfin
c'était inscrit Jérôme dry donc
mécaniquement j'ai lu monsieur Éric
martinau merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie
d'avoir pris en compte notre rapport de
contrôle sur les contrôles en
agriculture avec ma collègue Anne
lorblin et comme vous je suis très
sensible sur le contrôle de l'origine de
nos produits agricoles comment
pensez-vous lutter contre la
francisation et la fraude qui est aussi
une nécessité une évidence pour sauver
notre agriculture merci je vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur Fournier merci
Monsieur monsieur le ministre la filière
bio vous alerte de depuis longtemps vous
avez dit tout à l'heure vous vouez pas
que des agriculteurs bio déconvention il
aurait peut-être fallu en son temps
d'ailleurs maintenir les aides au
maintien qui était une manière de
l'éviter mais aujourd'hui les
agriculteurs bio vous disent 00 millions
c'est une homone ça fait 800 800 € par
exploitation si on ramène au nombre
d'exploitation bio dans notre pays il
vous demande près de 300 millions
d'euros il vous demande 145 € par
hectare en services environnementaux que
leur répondez-vous deuxème question sur
le plan écofyo vous voulez remplacer
l'indicateur NODU que vous critiquez par
probablement et si je voudrais vous
interroger là-dessus par l'indicateur
HRI 1 qui est lui encore plus criticable
puisquil qui n'ira pas vers la réduction
et peut même créer des contradictions
assez fortes donc je vous interroge la
suus puis troisème élément êtes-vous
prêt à mettre en place des ind
indemnisation pour les agriculteurs bio
qui voient leur champ contaminés par le
prufol car et autres insecticides ou
autres produits problématiques merci
Monsieur Perro
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre tout d'abord merci pour
l'action qui a été menée auprès du
Premier ministre durant ce conflit élu
d'une circonscription agricole je serai
vigilant à vos côté j'accompagnerai bien
évidemment les politiques publiques
qu'on mènera dans les mois à venir comme
vous le savez la question de l'eau est
centrale le varen de l'eau ainsi que les
annonces du président de la République
ont mis en lumière ce thème prédominant
pour
l'agriculture à présent les exploitants
attendent des actions sur des sujets
concrets comme celui du stockage quand
il est
opportun comment mieux les accompagner
et leur donner un cadre clair plus
généralement le sujet de l'eau nécessite
une meilleure visibilité dans la chaîne
de décision et des différents Act
mobilisé aussi dans quelle mesure
pouvons-nous soutenir davantage au plus
près du terrain ce qui nous nourrisse
sur l'utilisation et la préservation de
la ressources au-delà des annonces de
simplification ne sous-estimons pas ce
sujet capital pour notre souveraineté et
la pérennité de notre agriculture merci
merci beaucoup monsieur
Tavel merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre l'agriculture
française souffre d'un très grand mot
c'est le double discours que vous
incarnez encore à cet instant vous
prétendez vous êtes opposé à l'accord du
mercosour alors même que la Commission
européenne a confirmé que les
négociations se poursuivaient pour qui
prenez-vous les français pour qui
prenez-vous les agriculteurs français
sinon pour de nouveau d'indon d'une
mauvaise farce européenne il faut
stopper les accords de nég de libre
échange il faut que la France retire son
accord à tout mandat de négociation et
pas attendre tranquillement le 10 juin
que les élections européennes soient
passées pour signer cet accord comme
vous vous préparez à le faire deuxème é
de double discours vous ventez les 20 %
de produits bio dans la restauration
collective nos collectivités le maire de
fach tuménil dans le Nord Patrick prisi
fait 51 % dans sa commune par contre
dans une région la région Pays de la
Loire de Madame maenc où votre propre
parti le modem est dans la majorité
c'est moins de 10 % et c'est même en
recul d'une année sur l'autre quand
allez-vous cesser votre double discours
merci Madame
lepé merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre la Commission
européenne proposé de réviser la
direction relative ou la directive
pardon relative aux émissions
industrielles les ED
euh bien sûr pour tendre vers une
neutralité carbone 2050 la Commission a
ainsi souhaité inclure un plus grand
nombre d'élevages conventionnels
industriel de volaill et de porort en
abaissant les seuils de classement IED
et les grandes installations d'élevage
bovin si ces derniers sont d'orénavant
exclus du dispositif les filières
avicoles et porcines risquent quant à
elles d'être sérieusement impacté des
nouvelles contraintes encore pour nos
agriculteurs des contraintes coûteuses
mais surtout on risque de fragiliser la
majorité des élevages à capitaux
familiaux en Europe au profit de
consortium agroindustriel quelle est
votre position et celle du Gouvernement
en la matière et celle aussi de monsieur
le Président de la République et de
Madame vaner lyen merci merci Monsieur
parl Monsieur
B merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre la situation de l'riculture
française de l'agriculture française de
la viticulture odudoise en particulier a
été explosive ces derniers jours et ce
n'est pas forte de vous avoir prévenu à
plusieurs reprises malgré vos annonces
des zones d'ombre persistent sur la
concurrence des vins espagnols et les
viticulteurs ont besoin de clarté au
risque de voir des manifestations et de
blocage se multiplié plus de 4 millions
d'hectolitres de vin sont importés
chaque année d'Espagne nous nous savons
pourtant que la viticulture espagnol
utilise des produits phytosanitaires
interdits en France et que la
viticulture vit une crise majeure
monsieur le ministre comment se fait-il
que le vin espagnol puisse entrer sur le
territoire français sans aucun contrôle
sanitaire qui permettrait de diminuer
drastiquement cette concurrence
déloyable notamment pour les
viticulteurs du sud de la France et
particulièrement chez moi dans l'ude je
vous remercie merci Monsieur botorel
Merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre le secteur agricole a rappelé
ces dernières semaines combien les
normes et le droit peuvent s'avérer
difficilement applicables sur le terrain
par exemple coco de pimpol cette
légumineuse aux caractéristiques
gustatives exceptionnell a presque
toujours ét défendu en P en filet
plastique du fait de son humidité la loi
AGC a souhaité troquer le plastique
contre le carton dans une volonté de
réduction des embellages plastiques
cette nécessité partagé par le secteur
qui a lourdement investi pour adapter
les conditionnements et c'était pas sans
peine mais la loi s'applique
difficilement au coco dont l'humidité ne
permet pas une conservation dans le du
carton de la même manière imposer
aujourd'hui je dis bien aujourd'hui des
chaussures de sécurité au plumeurs de
coco faut-il jamais avoir plumé des coco
pour savoir qu'il est pas indispensable
des chaussures de sécurité
indépendamment du risque identifié dans
les exploitations apparaît
disproportionné n'est pas adapté au
terrain monsieur le ministre le secteur
est en attente de simplification
beaucoup m'ont exprimé cette demande sur
les barrages et nous législateurs devons
nous interroger sur l'applicabilité sur
le terrain des normes que nous votons et
disposition aussi comment envisagez-vous
de simplifier la déclison opérationnelle
de vos normes y compris pour le coco de
Pinol merci beaucoup monsieur
Dubois merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre une question
pragmatique sur les conséquences des
contraintes sanitaires liées à la MHE
depuis le sommet de élevage de Cournon
début octobre l'ensemble des beauvins
reproducteurs notamment de race
limousine vendu par les éleveurs
sélectionneurs corésiens sont bloqués en
ferme et ne peuvent être exportés seules
certaines organisations de producteurs
peuvent aller au bout du processus de
vente en plaçant quelques animaux en
quarantaine en zone indemne après avoir
respecté le protocole sanitaire défini
par le GDS si le décret publié prend
effectivement en charge les frais
vétérinaire il mériterait d'être élargi
à l'ensemble des frais inhérentss à la
quarantaine et au transport jusqu'en
zone indemne pour atténuer les frais
supplémentaires à la charge des éleveurs
la MHE risquant de s'installer
durablement il est primordial qu'un
protocole unique européen au sein de
l'UE calqué sur le modèle du plan du GDS
s'appliquant déjà sur les exportations
de broutard soit mis en place monsieur
le ministre prévoyez-vous d'indemniser
les frais de carantaine de plus un
protocole unique au sein de Lie enverit
un bon message à nos agriculteurs qu'en
pensez-vous enfin un accord bilatéral
France-Portugal est sur le point d'être
conclu où en est-il je vous
remercie merci monsieur fornass merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre depuis le début de cette
audition votre position plus qu'
ambivalente pardon sur nombre de sujets
et la veux CLA de l'ambiguïé de vos
annonces qui va se traduire je le crains
par un sentiment de trahison chez chez
les agriculteurs en novembre dernier en
commission d'enquête phito vous avvez
affirmé les échecs des plans écofito sur
la base d'un indicateur le nou
totalement tronqué je vous je vous avais
alors expliqué les problèmes de cet
indicateur et vous aviez refusé l'idée
de modifier de le modifier 2 mois et une
crise agricole plus tard vous acceptez
enfin de changer cet indicateur
allez-vous retenir l'indicateur européen
hri1 qui indique une baisse de 35 % 10
an de l'usage des phyos en France tout
simplement parce que nous avons diminué
de 96 % les cmr1 les produits les plus
dangereux par ailleurs Madame Van
derleyen a annoncé le retrait du
règlement sûr dans ce contexte
allez-vous abandonner le plan écofito
qui représenterait une une
surtransposition majeure et une
distorsion de concurrence gravissime
pour l'agriculture
française bien Madame B
pas
oui écoutez il y a il y a une solution
très simple sur les sujets d'indicateurs
de type de substance et cetera c'est de
passer à l'agriculture
biologique donc ma question comme
d'autres collègues elle est très simple
le Parlement il a voté 2611 millions
d'euros d'aide d'urgence pour
l'agriculture biologique et vous l'avez
remis en cause par le
493 et là il y a des questions des
parlementaires qui sont très claires
alors vous répondez on va faire une
réunion et cetera je constate qu'il y a
une sorte de catégorie d'agriculteur que
qui qui est pas prise en considération
c'est l'agriculture biologique or on est
dans une situation d'urgence absolue
d'urgence pour l'emploi d'urgence par
rapport à des filières et d'urgence
aussi pour le vivant par rapport à des
pratiques qui sont vertueuses alors
qu'on sait que sans verre de terre sans
pollinisateur sans agricultrices et sans
agriculteurs c'est une mystification
d'entendre assurer notre souveraineté
alimentaire
bien madame
blanc merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre ravi de savoir que
le rapport sur les contrôles dans les
exploitations agricoles vous a inspiré
effectivement c'est un un rapport que
nous voulions très concret et qui émane
du terrain donc c'est vrai que la
tutelle des contrôles par le préfet est
primordiale la question du désarmement
tel que ça a été énoncé par le Premier
ministre les désarmement de des agents
de l'ofb aussi est une question très
importante moi je voudrais simplement ci
cibler
ma question sur le sujet de la
multiplicité des normes aujourd'hui on a
très clairement des fondements
juridiques qui sont distincs qui peuvent
conduire à une appréciation
différente de la conformité d'une
situation identique ou d'un acte
identique
euh c'est notamment le cas pour la
gestion des la gestion des cours d'eau
c'est un peu déstabilisant monsieur le
ministre parce que comme vous écoutez
pas on sait pas tellement si
vous d'accord bah je sais pas c'est
quand même un pe Mame il reste 5
secondes votre question non ça c'est pas
sympa monsieur le Président non mais
j'ai 30 questions donc la question est
question de la multiplicité des normes
et donc je pense qu'il est primordial
que on accorde dans notre droit interne
un droit à l'erreur à nos agriculteurs
donc dans quelle mesure vous retiendrez
cette proposition qui émane de ce
rapport pour que nous reconnaissions un
droit à l'erreur pour nos agriculoup
nous passons à Monsieur oussin merci
Monsieur le Ministre quand cesserez-vous
votre double discours lors des
manifestations d'agriculteur vous avez
promis de revenir sur les
surtranspositions de règles européennes
parmi celles-ci la la filière betterrave
sucre dont 70000 emplois dépendent en
France demande d'être soumise aux mêmes
règles que ses voisins en matière de
pesticides l'interdiction par la France
de l'acétamit trip pour la betterave est
idéologique il est potentiellement
dangereux pour les abeilles mais tout le
monde le sait et les apiculteurs le
disent les abeilles ne vont pas sur les
betteraves car elles sont récoltées
avant floraison pourquoi refusez-vous
obstinément de réintroduire son usage en
attente d'Alternativ comme je l'ai
suggéré dans une proposition doit quelle
solution proposez-vous vos chèqus qui
palient les pertes que vous faites subir
au betterraviers sont un coût pour la
France alors que notre filière à
voocation a créé de la richesse en 2020
sans solution face à la jaunice de la
betterave la filière a déjà vacillé
après avoir perdu 30 % de sa récolte
assumez-vous de sacrifier notre filière
sucrière au profit de nos concurrents
étrangers ce qui risque de tuer tout un
équilibre local et d'aggraver le déficit
record de la balance commerciale merci
Monsieur
Caria merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre ministre la semaine
dernière vous avez annoncé la mise en
pose du plan écopyo alors même que
celui-ci est repoussé à plusieurs
reprises depuis 2008 c'est pourquoi
d'ailleurs lre de lors de votre venue
dans ma circonscription vendredi je vous
ai remis le livre secret toxique sur les
dangers des pesticides vous avancer je
cite rechercher une alternative crédible
permettant de réduire les pesticides ces
pesticides qui sont à l'origine de
cancer chez les paysans et les Riverin
ces pesticides qui sont à l'origine de
la disparition de masse des insectes la
base de la chaîne alimentaire qui
rendent les sols vivants et donc
nourriciers j'aurais donc deux questions
monsieur le ministre la première
pourquoi rechercher une alternative
crédible à la sortie des pesticides
alors que celle-ci est simple ne pas
laisser entrer des produits qui ne
respectent pas les mêmes normes sociales
et environnementales que nous il est
vital de ne pas niveler par le bas la
seconde quel est le coût sur
l'environnement et la société d'une
telle mise en pose et à contrario
pouvez-vous nous dire quels sont les
gains des fabricants de pesticides et
plus particulièrement de glyphosate sur
le marché français très bien merci
Monsieur
DEC merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre la principale revendication
des agriculteurs exprimé avec force ces
dernières semaines et la revalorisation
de leurs revenus et une juste
rémunération de leur travail au même
titre que tous les chefs d'entreprise
les agriculteurs aspirent à vendre leurs
produits à un prix qui puisse couvrir
leur coût de production une aspiration
légitime à laquelle n'ont pas répondu
plein les lois égalim un constat dont je
ne me réjouis pas c'est particulièrement
vrai s'agissant des éleveurs et plus
encore des éleveurs du Cantal et du
Massif central qui peuvent pourtant se
prévaloir d'un modèle particulièrement
vertueux qui s'appuie sur des prairies
naturelles qui contribue efficacement à
la fixation du carbone l'élevage
monsieur le ministre doit pouvoir
bénéficier de mesures concrètes et
fortes ce qui n'apparaît pas clairement
à la lecture de vos premières
propositions mais vous allez
certainement me rassurer d'où ma
question parmi les mesures que vous
envisagez de mettre en œuvre être-vous
disposé à porter un plan ambitieux à en
faveur de cet élevage vertueux et
durable pour reprendre le terme du
Manifeste pour l'élevage soutenu par les
élus du Massif Central je vous remercie
merci Madame
Pétel merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre vous connaissez
bien l'agriculture méditerranéenne et
vous savez que les bouches du Run sont
le le département où la production
maréchare est la plus
importante en PACA comme en Corse ou en
ocitanine nous subissons des pénuries
importantes de main d'œuvre or auvern
ronalpe ou occitan euh on certains
métiers qui sont classés en tension je
veux parler des filières maréchèes
l'arboriculture ou la viticulture eu
suite à la promesse de révision du
décret de 2021 relatif au métiers en
tenstion par Olivier du sopt en novembre
dernier vous avez vous-même fait de
récentes annonces pouvez-vous nous dire
quand pourront être
révisé pourra être révisée cette liste
des métiers en tenstion et est-ce que la
région PACA pourra faire partie pour les
filières maréchaires arboriculture et
viticulture de ses métiers en tension
autre petite question sur la DJA la
moyenne d'installation aujourd'hui dans
notre région est de 38 ans est-ce que le
plafond à 40 ans de DJ dja pardon ne
devrait-il pas être relevé au moins pour
certaines régions merci Monsieur
maisonet monsieur le ministre il aura
fallu attendre le soulèvement du monde
agricole pour que le ministre de
l'Économie mobilise S agent de la DGCCRF
pour contrôler l'application des lois
égalim comme l'avaient demandé les
collègues d'ailleurs Nicole lepé et
l'excellent Grégoire de fournass dans
leur rapport rendu en juillet 2022 sur
l'application de la loi égalim 2 depuis
la mise en application des deux lois
égalim qu'il s'agisse de la non
négociabilité de la matière première
agricole ou de l'interdiction des prix
dit abusivement bas nous n'avons jamais
jamais entendu parler ni de contrôle ni
de sanction pouvez-vous nous indiquer
clairement si des contrôles ont été
effectués avant
2024 ainsi que leur nombre par ailleurs
vous avez annoncé que trois entreprises
allaient être sanctionnées pourriez-vous
nous le confirmer et pourriez-vous
indiquer à la représentation nationale
le nom de ces trois entreprises merci
Madame
trouvé merci monsieur le ministre je
vais réagir à ce que vous avez dit tout
à l'heure c'est-à-dire que trop
d'écologie risquerait nous diminuer la
production agricole moi je me permets de
dire que ça me paraît une une vision
assez passéiste en fait de l'agriculture
parce que la modernité c'est justement
d'atteindre une double performance
économique et environnementale et vous
savez très bien qu'il y a aujourd'hui
des réseaux de développement je pense au
SIVAM au sedapa ou même à des chambres
d'agriculture qui aujourd'hui
travaillent sur des techniques des
technologies pour justement concilier
les deux par exemple les associations
céréales protéagineux des rendements qui
sont supérieurs au blé pur
diversification de rotation de culture
sur 10 ans on sait que ça diminue les
intrans chimiques par deux tout en ayant
à peu près le même rendement le 100%
herbag on sait que par exemple avec du
pâurage tournant dynamique et ben on
arrive à plus de valeur ajoutée plus
d'emploi plus d'environnement en plus ça
diminue les importations d'engra aoté
bref c'est bon pour la balance
commerciale donc moi j'ai cette question
parce que vous n'avez que robotique
génétique numérique en tête mais à quel
moment vous allez enfin faire une
politique pour soutenir
l'agroécologie
merci monsieur
vogeta
monsieur
vogetta votre micro monsieur vogetta
c'est voil bon monsieur le ministre en
1986 l'Espagne entit dans la ce il y a
un an le traité d'amitié entre la France
et l'Espagne éta signé à Barcelone
l'amitié entre nos deux pays est un bien
précieux mais cette amitié est en danger
quand nos partenaires espagnols
constatent les récentes attaques menées
en France contre leurs produits
agricoles que ce soit sur les barrages
routiers ou sur nos plateaux de
télévision pourtant grâce à l'Europe
esagne respecte aujourd'hui les mêmes
critères que la France pour sa
production bio pourtant la consommation
moyenne de pesticides par hectare de la
terre agricole en Espagne est un quart
inférieur au niveau français et bien sûr
n'oublions pas que si nous achetons
chaque année 9 milliards de produits
espagnols la France reste le premier
fournisseur de l'Espagne et nos
agriculteurs leur vendent chaque année 6
milliards d'euros de produits agricoles
français surtout du maïs du blé tendre
des produits laitiers du fromage des
poissons des crustacés ainsi que des
animaux vivants ma question est simple
et complexe à la fois comment convaincre
ceux qui comme Segolen royale d'autres
ici ni l'importance de l'intégration au
marché européen comment les convaincre
de renoncer à ce discours
protectionniste rétrograde merci Madame
Goulet merci monsieur le Président l'une
des grandes revendications de cette
mobilisation agricole a été la signature
des traités de libre échange qui placent
nos agriculteurs en situation de
concurrence déloyale le Premier ministre
a répondu très partiellement à cette
demande en évoquant une posture
provisoire sur le traité de libre
échange avec le Mercosur que
pourriez-vous nous dire des traités de
libre échange avec la Nouvelle-Zélande
le Kenya et le Chili que les députés
européens du groupe Ren ont voté et sur
lesquel vous avez été incapable de
négocier l'ajout de close miroir plus
largement votre position sur le traité
de libre échange avec le Mercosur
est-elle une légère inflexion pour
calmer temporairement les agriculteurs
ou comptez-vous continuer à à soutenir
des traités de libre échange et leur
concurrence déloyale au détriment de
l'agriculture
française merci j'ai monsieur de Courson
deux petites questions monsieur le
ministre dans l'avant projet de loi
d'orientation agricole il y avait un
volet installation mais pas de volet
transmission alors vu ce qui est en
train de se passer en agriculture est-ce
que vous êtes favorable à des mesures
simples sur la transmission consistant à
favoriser la transmission dans le cadre
familial c'està-dire des exonérations
avec contrepartie type dureille sur 10
ans 15 ans de maintien dans le caractère
familial
deè question on vous a posé beaucoup de
questions mais il y en a fort peu qui
ont posé une question de fond nous
étions avec Monsieur le l'ancien
ministre hier soir et le président des
COP a posé la grande question quelles
sont les grandes mesures à prendre pour
assurer la compétitivité des différentes
filière agricole
française merci Madame
Sabbatini merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre depuis l'été 2022
les pyinées orientales ont subi
plusieurs épisodes de sécheresse
exceptionneles ayant conduit à la mise
en place de mesures de restriction de
l'usage d'eau la production
départementale de vin et le rendement
des vignes sont à leur plus bas niveau
historique la trésorerie de nombreuses
exploitations viticoles est fragilisé
par la baisse significative de la
production en décembre 2023 je vous
avais alerté sur la nécessité de mettre
en place une urgence en urgence une aide
exceptionnelle sécheresse pour compenser
la trésorerie d'exploitation viticole
aujourd'hui c'est avec stupeur que les
viticuteurs des pyrinées orientales
constatent que seul 1,9 million d'euros
leur est attribué alors que les besoins
seraient de 10 millions d'euros le monde
viticle catalan ne serait se contenter
de 80 € par hectare alors que leurs
rendements sont les plus faibles de
France Monsieur le Ministre quelle
réponse concrète et immédiate avez-vous
apporter à ces viticulteurs qui
souffrent merci merci Monsieur de
l'pino monsieur le ministre c'est un
député de voclus qui vous parle 5e
département le plus pauvre nous sommes
en train de perdre la lavande la cerise
peut-être demain la fraise parce que les
produits phyau nécessaires pour lutter
contre les ravageurs sont interdits mais
ne sont pas remplacés alors ma question
porte sur le rôle de l'anè organisme qui
se cantonnait initialement ACC conseillé
le ministre concerné sur le plan
scientifique à charge pour le ministre
de prendre la décision politique de
limiter ou d'interdire un produit depuis
2015 lancess un pouvoir décisionnel
notamment sur la question des produits
phy pharmaceutiques utilisés dans
l'agriculture et agit de sa propre
autorité ce qui veut dire que le
scientifique a pris le pas aujourd'hui
sur le politique ma question est donc
très simple monsieur le ministre
comptez-vous reprendre la responsabilité
politique des décisions d'interdiction
et dans l'immédiat allez-vous accorder
des dérogations dans le cas des impasses
techniques je vous remercie merci
Monsieur Lecamp
oui merci monsieur le Président il
s'agit d'une question de mon collègue
Pascal Lavergne qui nous suit depuis son
L l'hôpital et à qui on a une pensée
pour lui en ce moment il travaille avec
son collègue Jean-Luc fugit
ou fugit sur une PPL visant à quitter le
domaine de l'expérimentation pour rendre
définitif les traitements par drone sur
les vignobles en pente ou sur les
plantations de bananiier selon leurs
investigations ce qui est prévu à
l'article 82 d'galim ressemble fort à
une surtransposition du droit européen
seriez-vous monsieur le ministre ouvert
à travailler sur le sujet les vignerons
les planteur de bananers les ouvriers
qui appliquent les traitements attendent
cette mesure je vous remercie merci
beaucoup je crois que là on a épuiser
toutes les questions monsieur Girardin
excusez-moi allez-y madame dub müer
allons-y allez-y monsieur Girardin
allezy merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre nous avons tous été
témoins ces dernières semaines de la
forte mobilisation des agriculteurs
partout en Europe qui ont exprimé leur
colère de ne pas pouvoir vivre de la
vente de leur production je tiens à
saluer ici la mobilisation de notre
gouvernement et particulièrement notre
ministre Marc fen qui ont su répondre
rapidement efficacement aux inquiétudes
légitimes des agriculteurs français la
réalité c'est que ce mouvement de colère
est aussi liés à des facteurs européens
tels que les distorsions de concurrence
mais aussi les recours par les grandes
centrales d'achat européennes à des
contournements de la législation
française qui permet grâce au loi égalim
1 et 2 de garantir un prix minimum
d'achat aux agriculteurs français qui
pâtissent souvent de la guerre des prix
entre la grande distribution et les
fournisseurs de l'agroindustrie dans ce
contexte le président de la République
annoncait jeudi dernier depuis Bruxelles
souhaitait la mise en place d'un égalim
Européen pour garantir une rémunération
des agriculteurs à juste prix et faire
de l'agriculture une exception française
monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous nous
dire ce que pourrait être les grandes
lignes de ce projet égalim européen je
vous remercie merci Madame Virginie dub
Mulard merci monsieur le Président ma
question porte sur la question de la
prédation toujours aussi présente en
overver dronalpe où le nombre de Lou est
visiblement sous-estimé par l'ofb du
coup le département de Haute Savoie a
mené et financé une étude en lien avec
la Fédération des chasseurs qui évalue
aujourd'hui une population s'élevant de
80 à 105 loups sur notre département
compte tenu du désarroi et de la
détresse de nos agriculteurs quel est
votre plan d'action pour la sauvegarde
de l'élevage de montagne entendez-vous
soutenir le déclassement du loup
d'espèces strictement protégé à espèces
protégé au niveau européen je vous
remercie merci j'ai monsieur potier et
merci monsieur le Président moi je vais
vous dire en cette fin de de de dialogue
qu'on a eu aujourd'hui avec vous mon
sentiment monsieur le ministre le le
plus le le plus profond c'est que en
répondant ce que j'aiaelais par le bas à
cette crise vous avez lâché les fauves
aujourd'hui on met en cause l'autorité
scientifique aujourd'hui on dit l'
grroécologie c'est une option
aujourd'hui au nom de la souverereaineté
alimentaire on est prêt à faire à peu
près n'importe quoi je dis vraiment que
sur la bataille culturelle ces semaines
là ont été un désastre alors je vous
invite notamment sur la base de la
commission d'enquête sur les pesticides
qui repose exclusivement sur de la
science certifiée par des P qui repose
sur des rapports qu'a produit votre
propre gouvernement sur des rapports
institutionnels est-ce que nous
engagions un dialogue qui soit pas une
manipulation et qu' nous regardions sur
tous les sujets point sur point comment
sur la question de la phytopharmacie on
peut réconcilier production alimentaire
santé environnementale et santé humaine
il y a 26 propositions il y en a pas une
et l'histoire de l'indicateur européen
c'est l' indicateur qui est des qualités
qui répondent à un C des charges et
c'est pas l'instrumentalisation dans un
camp ou dans l'autre sur ce dialogue là
nous sommes prêts merci merci Monsieur
Topia
oui merci monsieur le Président alors en
mon gascin je suis un peu cabourut pour
le dire en bon français tétu monsieur le
ministre je vous a envoyé trois
courriers depuis juillet de l'année
dernière je vous ai interpellé en
commission dans l'hémicycle avec des
amendements vous n'avez toujours pas
répondu au budget quielle être dédié
pour le MU il y a 80 millions d'euros le
GER s touché il faut 25 million d'euros
aujourd'hui si on fait si on prend les
derniers courriers que vous avez envoyé
c'est 5 millions d'euros pour le
département comment faisons-nous pour
accompagner nos agriculteurs qui sont
largement touchés par le mou et ces 80
millions correspondent aussi à des
problèmes de l'éos de l'UD où là c'est
plutôt la sécheresse qui est touchée
donc effectivement il faut que qu'il y
ait des engagements beaucoup plus
forts bien est-ce que tout le monde a pu
parler et poser sa question oui une fois
deux fois trois fois et bien monsieur le
ministre après c'estes plus de 30
questions je pense euh c'est à vous et
euh allez faire vite voilà je vous
laisse libre de du temps de réponse
monsieur le ministre parce que j'ai une
petite contrainte ensuite mais je vais
répondre essayer de répondre mais un peu
à la cavalcade pardon
euh non personne ne compte sacrifier le
bio donc c'est pas le sujet pour qui
sont Barr en fait oui en plus il y en a
qui sont pas c'està dire que je je
répond question il va répondre à tous
ceux qui restent voilà je dis
tranquillement j'ai toujours répondu aux
questions vous inquiétez pas tout va
bien se passer
euh sur la question sur la question des
cantines scolaires et vous dites est-ce
que est-ce qu'on va imposer dans il est
plus là mais le député qui me posait la
question monsieur Lopez me demander
comment on impose dans les contintines
scolaires je suis sûr que vous serez
après avec les élus pour dire vous avez
imposé aux élus et maintenant il va
falloir mettre des moyens pour le faire
donc va falloir qu'on choisiss soit
c'est la libre administration des
collectivités soit c'est la tutelle on
peut pas faire les deux et donc il me
semble et deux si on commence à se dire
que quand les règles ne nous conviennent
pas on sort bah autant mais après tout
ça s'assume comme position on peut aussi
sortir de l'Union européenne je pense
qu'on demander aux Anglais ce qu'ils en
pensent je pense pas que ce soit
l'élément plus avantageux sur le
sujet monsieur Pilato sur la
souveraineté alimentaire au-delà de de
votre propos la souveraineté alimentaire
pardon c'est la capacité à se nourrir à
nourrir sa propre population c'est aussi
la capacité à se dire qu' il y a des
sujets sur lequels d'autres peuvent nous
nourrir et de de oui et de de sécuriser
quand nous aurons des années de
sécheresse si vous êtes juste à faire
demandez aux Espagnols ce qui s'est
passé cette année sur le sur les Réal
ils ont ils peuvent pas couvrir leur
besoins parce qu'ils ont de la
sécheresse donc il faut aussi qu'on ait
des échanges et une capacité à échanger
avec d'autres pour s'assurer que notre
propre souveraineté est assurée et que
nous puissions assurer la souveraineté
alimentaire des autres oui donc ça se
fait dans une logique d'échange avec les
autres et pas dans une logique
autarsique c'est pas simplement
l'autosuffisance c'est c'est pas
simplement l'autosuffisance non parce
que l'autosuffisance ça c'est comme si
vousz faisiez rentrer des facteurs de
production et qu'à la fin vous étiez sûr
d'avoir 50 quinau ça marche pas comme ça
l'agriculture vous mettez les facteurs
de production une année vous avez 20 une
année vous avez 80 c'est c'est une
réalité biologique he pardon et c'est
bien de se le rappeler de dire que si
vous dites je suis sûr d'avoir 50 quinau
tous les ans vous êtes sûr qu'à un
moment vous allez avoir une famine c'est
garanti sur facture c'est garanti sur
facture c'est la vie du monde il suffit
de regarder l'histoire c'est ce qu'elle
a raconé sur la question de la
francisation bah c'est surtout la
question des la vérité c'est les
contrôles dans les grandes surfaces
c'est la contrôle aussi je pense au 20
sur un certain nombre de pratiques qui
font comment dirais-je qui viennent
tromper manifestement qui pratiquent de
la tromperie vis-à-vis des consommateurs
évidemment c'est sur ces sujets là qu'il
faut travailler monsieur Fournier m'a
interrogé sur la question de les aides
au maintien je rappelle qu'elles ont été
compensées par une une déduction fiscale
d'un montant au moins équivalent à ce
qui était les aides au maintien donc
c'est pas un débat budgétaire après
j'entends les chiffres ça rejoint ce que
d'autres étaient dit et d'autres ont dit
c'est on vient m'aligner des chiffres
sans qu'on vienne m'argumenter aussi de
tout c'est 300 c'est 500 c'est un
milliard je rappelle que le sujet
principal du bio c'est que on est sur
une perte de chiffre d'affaires faire de
1,5 milliards d'euros au niveau national
c'est ça le sujet donc c'est aussi par
là qu'il faut qu'on essaie c'estàdire
qu'il faut qu'on sollicite la
consommation c'est aussi par là qu'on
résoudra la crise sinon on fera
simplement que de courir derrière la
crise mais je répète que le travail est
en cours avec eux il me semble que c'est
un élément important monsieur Perro a
raison de m'alerter sur la question de
l'eau il y a à la fois des sujets de
simplification et il y a des sujets de
quellees conclusion on tire de
l'arythmie climatique telle qu'elle se
développe il y a un sujet d'arythmie
climatique parlez-en aux gens du pas
decalais parlez-en aux gens
euh du sud de langdoc Rousillon ex
langdoc Rousillon il y a une arithmie
climatique eux c'est 3 ans sans eau et
d'autres c'est en permanence des
inondations et donc il y a quelque chose
qui doit se penser de la façon de gérer
le cycle de l'eau alors ça veut pas dire
qu'il faut tout parier uniquement sur
les réserves on a besoin de réserve mais
je pense au sujet de l'eau des pyèes
orientale ou de l'héau les réserves es
sont à sec aujourd'hui donc il faut
aussi qu'on pense le système dans une
résilience à des épisodes où pendant 1
an 2 ans 3 ans il y a pas d'eau et donc
il faut qu'on on pense les deux systèmes
c'est les réserves pas que les réserves
dans un cycle long et c'est ça qu'il
fautetraavailler sur
le monsieur Tavel m'interrogé d'abord je
vrais le
rassurer le modem ne fait pas partie de
la majorité de Madame Morancé il était
sur une autre liste c'est juste pour la
non excusez-moi je m'occupe un peu des
élections dans mon parti je sais à peu
près à qui j'ai donné les investitures
c'est à Monsieur drugi alors
pardon B si Monsieur drugi il est bien
en région pay Loire il était bien tête
de liste bon
voilà la question c'est pas de savoir
s'il a gagné ou il a perdu puis qu'il
parle de la majorité de Madame maenc ne
soyez pas blessante madame Blin ça
arrive les défaites c'est vrai donc et
on a
besoin donc on a besoin non
mais arrêtezv allez on laisse monsieur
le ministre nous ne sommes pas le modème
n'est pas dans la majorité deuxième
élément si je sais que ça vous passionne
l'affaire des pays de Loir mais moi je
j' essayer de répondre à votre question
euh vous auriez pu citer destas d'autres
régions qui et donc moi je fais pas je
pense que nous avons besoin de nous
saisir collectivement avec l'ensemble
des collectivités qu'elle fasse en sorte
qu'elle répondent à égalim donc c'est
pas la peine de dire Madame morencé il y
a d'étas d'autres régions y compris avec
lesquels vous gouvernez parfois dans
lesquels il y a pas le l'atteint des
objectifs d' Galim c'est la vie et donc
il faut qu'on fasse un effort collectif
et c'est un choix politique me
semble-t-il important sur la question
euh monsieur bartè sur
les pouvez pas reprocher aux Espagnols
mais je trouve que le discours ça
rejoint ce qu'a dit Monsieur vogetta le
discours qu'on a vis-à-vis de l'Espagne
c'est un c'est un discours qui est
absolument toxique je vais vous dire
quand il y a eu le sujet de la MHE il a
suffit que je passe un coup de fil à mon
collègue espagnol pour lui dire alors
qu'il n'était pas obligé de le faire et
qu'il a dérogé à une réglementation il
aurait bloqué les beauvins à la
frontière espagnole je vous raconte pas
les dégâts sur le sur la filière donc
attention quand même à ne pas jeter l'
prop si nous avons de la
surtransposition c'est à nous qu'il faut
s'en prendre et pas aux
autres non mais et donc c'est pour ça
qu'on fait un travail de de sur queles
sont les surtransposition ques sont les
Simp ation et qu'elle la trajectoire
européenne pardon deuxème élément il y a
un certain nombre d'opérateurs y compris
français qui joue un jeu sur lequel on
va regarder compris en terme de contrôle
et qui profitant de la crise font
rentrer des vins d'Espagne mais il y a
des acteurs français dans le jeu donc on
va pas se raconter l'histoire donc il
faut aussi chacun prendre ses
responsabilités donc je suis d'accord
avec vous sur le fait de ce qui se passe
mais n'allons pas dire c'est la faute
des
Espagnols ah si vous avez dit un peu ça
pardon sur le coco de pimpul cher
monsieur
euh bah ça c'est typiquement voyez la
loi àc tout le monde a trouvé que
c'était formidable c'est voilà une jolie
surtransposition rés une très très belle
surtransposition et prenons chacun notre
part parce qu'elle a été votée assez
largement en plus dans l'hémicycle le
deuxième sujet c'est que maintenant il y
a une réglementation européenne qui
vient en espérant qu'elle soit la même
que la nôre parce que si elle est pas la
même que la nôre ça fait quoi à ce que
dit ce que débat que j'ai avec Monsieur
potier suffit pas de dire moi j'ai ma
réglementation française elle est
tellement mieux disante parce que nous
on est tellement plus fort que les
autres puis les autres l'Union
européenne fait sa propre réglementation
si demain on a une réglementation
européenne qui dit l'inverse de ce qu'on
a dit en France on va redemander aux
acteurs des fruits et légumes de changer
leur machine donc c'est ça qui est
toxique dans la
surtransposition c'est de faire en sorte
qu'on ait des règles quand après un
moment l'Europe se saisit et qu'elle ne
fait pas les mêmes règles et donc on a
besoin sur la loiag comme sur d'autres
et donc il y a un travail qui va être
fait sur la question de la
simplification là aussi comment ça c'est
pas un sujet AGC c'est un autre sujet
c'est un sujet santé au travail ou droit
du travail me semble-t-il euh monsieur
Dubois sur les question d'export euh sur
la question d'export euh oui on est en
train de travailler au niveau européen
pardon je reprends la je me ressaisis de
la question pour faire en sorte qu'on
fluidifie les choses et que ça vienent
alléger les procédures le la MHE n'était
pas classée au bon endroit si je peux
dire parce qu'elle était émergente et
émergente très peu présente en en Europe
désormais qu'elle va monter partout
parce que je vous garantis qu'elle va
être en France puis qu'elle va monter en
latitude donc on travaille aujourd'hui
on on met en place un travail avec les
unions européennes pour avoir des règles
de gestion euh qui sont euh qui soient
ouvertes on ouvre au fur et à mesure
avec un certain nombre de pays européens
on a un travail qu'on continue avec les
Algériens parce que c'est un marché qui
est important et avec les Portugais
enfin bref le travail se poursuit le
gros du volume était quand même Espagne
Italie mais il faut mais même si c'est
des petits volumes ça vient déstabiliser
le marché et certains viennent s'en
saisir pour évidemment en profiter si je
peux dire les choses aussi là-dessus euh
monsieur de Fournas il y a pas
d'ambiguïé des annonces d'ailleurs vous
les verrez compris sur les questions de
simplification après c'est pas aussi
simple que ça de transformer en 15 jours
donc des choses qui datent parfois de 15
20 ou 30 ans hein parce que quand on
regarde et qu'on ouvre le moteur il y a
des choses qui datent de ce de de ce
registre là donc il y a pas d'ambigué
des annonces par ailleurs je vous je
vous dis juste un truc factuellement
ecofito n'est pas une
surtransposition ecofito est la
traduction d'une directive européenne ça
n'est pas une surtransposition au sens
strict du terme donc ne venons pas ne
venons pas demander àcofite de faire ce
qu'il fait pas Madame Blin sur la
question des contrôles je vous écouter
je vous assure rassurez-vous on s'est vu
d'ailleurs dans mon bureau avec Monsieur
martinau sur la question des contrôles
l'objectif je il y a deux choses un il
faut qu'on ait des contrôles qui soient
uniques c'est ce qu'a annoncé le le
Premier ministre deuxièmement la
question du droit à l'erreur alors le
droit à l'erreur il est double c'est
est-ce que c'est les sujets législatifs
et c'est aussi les sujets de pratique du
contrôle le droit à l'erreur c'est aussi
la façon dont on pratique le contrôle et
donc on a un travail aussi à faire
là-dessus parce que je pense que c'est
aussi tout le monde peut avoir des cas
où on dit ok je vous ai vu je vous
sanctionne pas là mais si je revois vous
voyez ce que je dire c'est valable pas
que pour les contrôles Deb c'est valable
pour toute une série de contrôles et
donc il faut qu'on active mieux le droit
à l'erreur qu'on a mis en place
d'ailleurs dans la PAC qui est venu
complexifier un certain nombre de choses
du coup on a des délais qui sont
beaucoup plus longs parce que le droit à
l'erreur ça donne le temps à des gens
qui avaient pas coché la CE de revenir
au mois de novembre du coup je peux pas
les payer au mois de novembre bon mais
le droit à l'erreur je suis d'accord
c'est un sujet sur lequel il faut
travailler évidemment monsieur vogeta
j'y reviens pas parce que mais vous j'ai
déjà répondu en parti à la question et
nous avons fait en sorte euh que les
Espagnols qui sont rentrés dans depuis
longtemps dans l'Union européenne qui
ont été très actifs avec nous sur
beaucoup de sujets européens et dont on
a grandement besoin parce qu'on a besoin
de partenaires avec lesquels on
crédibilise une confiance et donc merci
de ce que vous faites et ce que font
d'autres pour pour cela monsieur de
Courson sur la question de transmission
oui ça sera bien la question là après il
y a une traduction qui sera plutôt
PLF
comment non je dis il y aura des choses
posées dans la LOA mais la traduction
budgétaire c'est c'est le PLF après le
mécanisme du train a l'air assez peu
opérant mais on aura l'occasion d'un
débat et de discuter sur cette question
là-dessus il me semble que c'est un
élément il y avait quelqu el chose
d'ailleurs sur le le FSA dans la les les
premières étapes de de concertation je
finis juste rapidement madame Sabatini
pour c'est c'est bien Sabatini euh
d'abord on serait témoin que on n pas du
tout laissé tomber les PO depuis la
crise sécheresse on a travaillé sur la
question de l'eau pour pas qu'il se
retrouve au régime sexe qui était le
grand risque c'est nous qui avons pris
la décision avec le préfet de l'époque
deuxièmement on a mis 2 millions d'euros
sur les pecs pour les cotisations
sociales 1 million d'euros sur l'élevage
6 million d'euros sur la réserve de
crise sur l'bor agriculture euh il y a
80 millions qui ont été ventilés en
fonction d'une règle de répartition qui
était assez simple qui était la règle
des des volumes produits alors
évidemment première intention les PO
sont moins euh bénéficiaires je vous
rappelle que sur les 80 millions il y a
à peu près entre 8 et 9 millions de
réserves c'est-à-dire qu'il n'ont pas
été ventilés évidemment ça vient
répondre au sujets comme ceux des
pyrenes orientales je suis assez serein
pour vous le dire on n pas du tout
abandonné les pyenes oriental et
onabandonnera pas plus la visiculture
que les autres y compris dans l'année
qui s'annonce compliqué et on n' pas
fini parler des Pyrénées Orientales
j'aimerais qu'on en parle plus
positivement que ce qu'on est obligé de
faire sur la question chéchesse donc on
nabandonnera pas les viticulteurs de des
Pyrénées Orientales il me semble que
c'est ça me permet de répondre à
Monsieur topiac 20 millions par-ci 300
millions par là Monsieur topiac on
essaie de travailler aussi on peut pas
je je vous le dis
très tranquillement on peut pas
simplement me dire c'est 20 millions et
c'est comme ça faut qu'on puisse le
documenter on a essayé de répondre à
quelque chose qui n'était pas qui
n'était pas normalement dans le scope
qui était de répondre à la question du
mildu parce que les les assurances ne
couvrait pas et que rien ne couvrait
donc on on a entré et intégré le midu et
je suis très heureux qu'on a fait
intégrer ça y compris pour le Gers on va
regarder les dossiers on en parlera mais
cette façon de dire si c'est 20 là ça
veut dire qu'il faut quoi un milliard un
milliard et demi 2
milliards très bien monsieur topiac mais
euh monsieur le C sur la question des
drones oui ça c'est un sujet qu'on va
réintégrer dans parce qu'il me semble
qu'on a une on verra sous quel vecteur
mais en tout cas qu'on va réintégrer
parce qu'on a une expérimentation qui a
plutôt donné des signaux alors je vois
bien la grande crainte des des drones
mais dès lors que ça vient réduire les
les usages et des applications qui soit
plus localisé je vois pas pourquoi on se
préit de cette technologie là moi non
plus surtout qu'il y a une
expérimentation on a lané une
expérimentation
elle a l'air conclusive alors si on fait
des expérimentations qu' sont pas elles
sont conclusives et qu'on dit on en
tient pas compte c'est un peu
regrettable me semble-t-il sur monsieur
Gardin sur égalim c'est le c'est oui euh
vous êtes un peu ça doit être un sujet
marné vous posez des des questions qui
me demanderaient une heure donc il y a
la question de monsieur de Courson que
j'ai laissé de côté sur comment on fait
la souveraineté parce que c'est pas dans
le temps à parti mais évidemment on
reviendra dans le dans le la
compétitivité pardon euh mais ça vient
ça vient s'inspirer de ce qu'on fait sur
égalimme c'est-à-dire une une
rémunération qui qui préserve la matière
première agricole c'est le même principe
qui doit s'appliquer à cela il me semble
que c'est un élément important madame
dumumulire sur la
prédation je je j'ai du mal à rentrer
dans les sujets de comptage parce que il
faut qu'on qu'on expertise et
contreexertise euh je pense qu'il faut
on est en train de travailler d'ailleurs
sur la manière de compter y compris
d'ailleurs pour avoir un indicateur qui
soit de même nature au niveau européen
parce que les uns compent les meutes les
autres content l'ADN et les traces de je
sais pas quoi enfin bref faut qu'on ait
quelque chose si on veut compter les
populations au niveau européen qu'on
compte pareil parce que si on compte pas
pareil là aussi on mélange des chous et
des carottes deuxième élément je crois
que pourraz reconnaître pour ceux qui
sont concernés qu'on a fait un travail
assez profond sur le plan lou y compris
sur la question des indemnisations y
compris sur la question du
simplification des tirs là aussi c'est
des sujets de simplification y compris
sur un sujet qui qui n'avait jamais été
ouvert c'est le statut du loup puisque
la les États-membres seront appelés à
délibérer sur très protégé à protéger
pour faire en sorte qu'on ait des
mesures de gestion qui soient de notre
nature cont tenu d'une population qui a
atteint un niveau satisfaisant pour
l'espèce et pour la génétique il faut
qu'on se pose des questions mais c'est
nous qui avons ouvert la boîte avec
d'autres mais c'est quand même nous qui
avons ouvert la boîte on n'est pas au
bout du chemin en tout cas il me semble
qu'on a av on a avancé enfin Monsieur
top j'ai répondu monsieur
potier personne n'a ouvert les vannes
pardon par que si vous disiez ça vous
irez m'expliquer pourquoi il y a des
manifestations sur le même registre en
Allemagne sur le même registre en
Espagne sur le même registre en Italie
sur le même registre en Grèce sur le
même registre en Pologne faut peut-être
qu'on s'interroge s'il y a des gens
autant de gens du monde agricole qui
commencent à dire la la la la
sédimentation de toutes ces normes nous
pose problème faut peut-être les écouter
ils ont ils ont peut-être pas
complètement tort c'est pas qu'un sujet
français vous dites vous vous avez
ouvert les vannes et alors les gens que
vous soutenez en Allemagne ils ont voyez
ce que je veux dire et quand je parle
avec mes collègues européens ils disent
qu'on a une P qui est trop compliquée
ils disent qu'on a des règles qui sont
inapplicables ils le disent tous donc il
faut qu'on se le dise c'est pas ouvrir
les vannes que d'essayer de regarder la
réalité des choses je suis sûr qu'on
peut partager ça mais il y a un moment
si on est complètement sourd à des
sujets qui posent problème avec des gens
qui ne peuvent plus produire de bonne
foi on fait quoi mais il y a aussi des
je j'essaie de trier vous le savez
d'ailleurs j'essaie de trier mais il y a
des gens qui de bonne foi disent je ne
peux plus produire je ne sais plus faire
vous avez un sujet dans les pyénes
orientales qui est un sujet d'accès
d'accès à l'eau vous leur proposez il va
falloir bien qu'on propose un modèle
plus résilient en terme de culture mais
aussi avec un sujet d'eau et c'est
valable dans les pyines orientales comme
c'est valable dans plein de départements
donc dire on fait le statut quo et ne
pas voir le problème qui se pose et dire
vous ouvrez les Vanes simplement parce
qu'on essaie d'écouter ce qui est la
réalité d'un problème lié euh en
particulier poussé très fortement par un
contexte géopolitique mais aussi par un
contexte climatique quelque chose doit
changer aussi on a une pâack dans son
fondement qui a été construite à quel
endroit dans la pâack dans le règlement
de base il y a quelque chose qui pense
des règlements
climatiques à quel moment dans la loi
sur l'au de 92 on parle de
l'arythmie des
précipitations bon c'est pas une insulte
de dire ça c'est juste que quelque chose
a changé quoi juste quelque chose a
changé et donc si on n pas capable
d'adapter nos politiques pardon de vous
le dire on fait fausse route alors moi
je fais la part euh de ce que j'ai à
faire mais je pense qu'il faut qu'on
fasse collectivement la part sinon on
envoie un signal aux agriculteurs de on
est totalement sourd et aveugle à des
réalités qui s'imposent à nous oui il y
a des gens qui ont pas envie des
transitions mais beaucoup d'entre eux
l'immense majorité d'entre eux ils ont
envie des transitions parce qu'ils ont
eux aussi pas envie qu'on vienne ce qui
a été fait pendant des mois et des
années les montrer du doigt ou les
laisser dans des situations d'impasse
enfin il faut plutôt les accompagner que
faire autre chose voilà monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés merci
beaucoup merci monsieur le ministre et
attendez fait question monsieur le
ministre nous a consacré 2 heures et
pour d'autres questions vous pouvez le
solliciter par ailleurs ainsi que son
cabinet j'ai
euh une dernière annonce à faire s'il
vous plaît par rapport à la mission
d'évaluation d'galim 2 que je vous avais
sollicit je vous avais soumise en début
de réunion nous avions nommé Frédéric
descrosyan lorbabo et Aurélie Trouvé
après avoir vu avec le président
chassigne et avec leslr donc le
président chassigne et Monsieur Julien
div se sont mis d'accord pour que ce
soit Julien div le 4e donc rapporteur de
cette mission évaluation pour au titre
de l'opposition personne y voit
d'inconvénient et donc les quatre
rapporteurs sont nommés pour le planning
des joursavenir demain à 7h30 nous
partons pour visiter le site alpine à
diep en compagnie de Sébastien jumelle
mardi 13 février nous aurons la
présentation du rapport d'application de
la loi accélération du nucléaire avec ma
breéjon et Sébastien jumelle nous aurons
aussi la loi accélération de la
production des énergies renouvelables
avec Henry Alfandari Éric botorel Maxime
lénet et Nicolas maisonnet
et ensuite le 14 février on aura
l'examen de deux propositions de loi qui
sont inscrites dans la niche socialiste
merci chers collègues et puis très bonne
soirée à demain matin 7h30 pour le
départ